this is jocko podcast number 321 with
echo charles and me jocko willink good
evening echo good evening
so
it's cold
wet
dark i've been awake for a few days
19 years old
it's hell week
it's kind of crazy
but i'm having fun
a bunch of people have quit
and you
do you have no idea who's going to quit
my boat my boat crew leader quit who he
was a prior quitter so he had been
already been to buds been to the fleet
realized he didn't want to be in the
fleet
got gone through the whole
administrative rigma role to get back to
buds
and he just quit
watching people quit
is crazy they quit so fast you can't
keep track of it it's just it's just a
mass exodus and so what happens is your
boat crew you're in a boat crew of six
or seven guys
organized by height
[Music]
because you need to be roughly the same
height to carry a boat on your head or a
log on your shoulder if you've got six
or seven guys you gotta be around the
same height so you're organized by
height so as people quit
you get less and less boat crews you
keep lining up to
adjust
who's in your boat crew
but by
by
late tuesday night or early wednesday
morning things start to settle down
meaning
most the people that are going to quit
have quit
and so now you see who's left then it's
again you have no idea who was going to
quit and you got all kinds of different
people tall
short stocky lean smart
some not so smart some introverts some
extroverts there's no stereotype there's
no stereotype there might be a public
stereotype of what is heals but it
doesn't exist actually in the seal teams
you have no idea who's going to make it
only the big frog man in the sky knows
who's gonna be a frog man down here on
earth
in my boat crew
end up with some solid guys
one of them is a quiet fella from
kentucky and he's holding strong his
name is chris
gifford
steady as a rock
calm
stoic
solid
and we kept paddling and we made it
through hell week and we both eventually
got assigned to seal team one
and ended up having some
pretty cool experiences together
and he ended up
with a career as a seal like me and a
ton of lessons learned along the way and
it's an honor to have him here with us
tonight to talk about his experiences
and share some of those lessons learned
chris
good to see you man thanks for coming by
thank you so much this is uh a bit
surreal because i'm a big fan of the
show and just to be here with with you
and echo and and talk about this stuff
this is uh it's awesome so thank you
thank you for having me
we're going to get into buds because i
don't remember a lot of buds
and so i'm hoping you can fill in some
holes along the way but before we get
there
let's start out the beginning let's
start about where you came from
yeah so i i grew up in kentucky and
lexington which is you know kind of a
college town
and um
it was
a great place to grow up and it's still
a great place today but
when i was in high school
i wanted to leave i was i was ready to
leave what would your mom and dad do so
my parents were divorced my
mom worked
later on she got remarried they owned a
body shop so uh they ran that um
and then my father was uh
in
not too far away in louisville and uh he
ran his own business so uh he did
was a
kind of an answering service for people
who
did uh
inspections house inspections so they
would call him he would set up the
appointments and uh and then just
fax the appointments to them
um but
who was more influential to me was
probably my my best friend's family
and uh he was
mr hall a great guy um and still is
today but uh he was retired are not
retired but he was in vietnam
uh in the army
and just you know kind of an outdoors
type person
and uh was
real instrumental in helping you know me
kind of
get into that
outdoor you know not staying inside
getting out and and being
in in nature more a big hunter
had a lot of uh guns and stuff which
made me more comfortable around it and
all this stuff made a big difference
later on because yeah being from
kentucky uh going to
san diego was was a big change and it
was pretty
evident early that uh that i would have
that now if i remember right you did you
were weren't you an electrician or
something yeah so
the as i was
wanting to go into the military
when
i was 14 my best friend and i
went to gulfport mississippi
to visit his uncle who was a
cb chief
and we spent a week there with him
and he was great he took us to the base
kind of exposed us to all that and
that's when i was like yeah this i think
the navy is a good way to get out of
kentucky it's a good
uh
good environment
this is the type of culture i want to be
in
and
my best friend and i at the time
were also
dive qualified so we had already been
through like the patty open water
he was
my friend was big into that and
so we kind of that was our hobby so we
go down to gulfport mississippi and uh
he takes us around and he said you know
if you like
scuba diving you might want to
look at the the seal teams and we're
like well we're the still teams so he
had the all hands magazine which was
about you know so this was mid-80s
which is the only information that that
was out at the time
and uh we looked through it and it's
like yeah this this sounds cool this is
i think this would be good
so we tried to do is my friend i tried
to do as much research as we could
and uh
we
kind of determined that you know you
know
and now in the navy you would call it a
poa m you kind of set up these
milestones on how to get to to a
targeted goal
and i knew that at the time
in order to
go to buds and be
a ceo you first had to go to an a school
so my thinking was okay if i got to do a
trade and i had a list of the
different the different source ratings
that you could be
to
to go to buds
i figured if i could learn this early
then
when i was in a school i could work out
more and i could focus on going to buds
so
my high school had a program to go to
vocational school
half of the day so the first half you
did your whatever required courses math
english whatever
and then the second half
you left the campus went to a vocational
school and you studied a trade
and
i chose electricity just because uh a
lot of my family were in construction
it was uh i would spend some summers
working for my uncles as a plumber and i
knew i didn't want to do that
so electrical work was a lot easier well
that wasn't easier but it was cleaner
cleaner yeah i wasn't you know scooping
[ __ ]
so uh it was um
so i i chose yeah electrical work and
with the whole intent of just learning
that so when i got to a school i didn't
have to study as hard i could just go to
the gym every night what was in the all
hands magazine
uh
you know it just had just cool pictures
i had the pictures but it kind of
outlined you know this what you have to
do to
uh
to to go to budge yeah you have to have
so many pull-ups so it's
the times on your runs your swims
um
they talked about the source rating so
it was all about just kind of how to get
into it very little was about you know
what they actually did did you read any
books uh like the
there's a couple books that predated you
and i going in the military going in the
navy did you read any of those i didn't
read any of you no no i i
when i was in high school i was a
mediocre student at best i knew
to join the navy all i had to do was
scratch was graduate with with a
three-pointed seat
and that's all
i did did you do any athletics i i did i
was a runner
and i ran distance and that was because
i was you know
like i am now you know very thin
long legs and uh i think it was like 135
at the time what's the distance so kind
of distances so for track
was to the two mile or yeah yeah it was
the two mile run the one mile run and
the half mile or 880
so my high school it was mostly all
sprinters
and there were very few distance runners
uh so it was it was good that
the coach kind of left us alone and uh
that's that's all i did was just go in
and run
miles and miles every day
and so that that was
kind of my strong point i did swim but
i didn't do the type of swimming that i
probably did to be competitive yeah i
think around my group of friends i was
probably a very good swimmer and i think
compared to the general population today
you were a good swimmer amongst your
nine friends in louisville kentucky yeah
exactly so uh but running running was
was definitely my strong point
so
you get in the navy what when you show
up to buds
what
what was your thoughts when you when you
showed up to buds
well i think
by that time i felt pretty comfortable
with with what
how we were or how how buds went and a
lot of that was because my best friend
again we both wanted to go in the teams
together but he was a year ahead of me
so he actually joined the navy
one year ahead and so he was kind of
communicating with me how things were
going
and
when i was in a school
i actually was here in san diego so on
the weekends i would take the bus over
to coronado
meet him and and you know hang out with
him and and kind of get some inside
uh but before that did he make it he did
he did yeah yeah what's he what team did
he go he went to stvs yeah and uh that
was uh
yeah he did one tour there and then he
got out went into the police force and
had
still has a great career doing that so
you had a good heads up as to what you
were going to be facing when you got to
buds i did and that year
while he was gone i was just so focused
on what i needed to do and i think one
of the issues that i had again i was a
good runner a decent swimmer but i'd
never lifted weights before and i didn't
even know where to start or
or definitely i
would have hurt myself so
i went to the
ymca and i met
a
former kentucky football star cisco
bryant coach bryant
and just
went in and said look and again
135 pounds 16 years old i said i want to
be a seal and he's like uh-huh
and uh i said you know here's my strong
points but i don't have any weight
training or anything and he mentored me
for that year i would go you know every
day that i could
and uh he worked with me and if anything
he kept me from getting hurt which i
think a lot of kids trying to go today
you know they they just push it too hard
and get hurt before they even go
but but he was uh he was a good mentor
to me and got me kind of that more
comfortable with my body my weight
and to be able to handle that so i felt
pretty good going to buds that and you
were good on pull-ups push-ups dips yeah
and
rope climbs and all that uh yeah yeah
he's the one who who kind of worked with
me on that and put me on a good program
to uh to be able to at least again make
make the markers and you know back then
not a lot of people knew about buds so
really all you had to do was you know
meet the minimum you weren't trying to
outperform at that time and i remember
doing one of the uh tests i think it was
the test right before you class up
you know they were like all right eight
pull-ups and you know they're trying to
get everybody through once you did your
eighth are like all right hop down next
and they were just trying to they just
didn't even care yeah you know it was
just trying to yeah if you were ready to
class up and you met the test then you
were ready to go they weren't you
weren't really competing i got a
confession to make
you just made me think of this
and i feel like
a dick
so there was a guy remember we had to do
that class up test
and you you count your buddy's reps
and my buddy who i know exactly who it
is because he ended up making it
on sit-ups
he didn't he was shy the number i didn't
know him at the time
and you know i think you had to do 75
sit-ups or something like this and he
did like
68. maybe even did like 72.
like for time or something you have two
minutes okay you have to do it's run
swim or actually swim run pull-ups
sit-ups push-ups something like that
good minimum numbers like you said chris
said the the minimum for pull-ups was
like eight yeah but that was it you do
eight okay you're good you're going in
the class
this guy who who oh i end up i know him
like later on i know he's a great guy
he's a good guy he's a great team guy
blah blah blah he did like
70
shy of the sit-ups and the instructor
came over he's like what was his number
and i'm like 71 fail
[Laughter]
you're such an [ __ ]
i feel bad dude
you know but at the time and also at
that time it was like you didn't know
who was making it you didn't and
i don't think we had really had that
attitude because i think you get into an
attitude of the class like you got to
help your friends out like help your
buddy and we weren't there yet because
we were just hey are we going to class
up and so i just and i also have like a
cold-blooded streak of honesty and it's
hard for me to lie about [ __ ]
and i actually had one person double one
time you're incapable of lying i'm like
probably pretty close so the instructor
asked me about 71 they're like fail cool
sorry bro
yeah
well that yeah that reminds me of when i
first got
to bud so i think when i got there the
class before is just classed up so
everyone that was waiting in that fourth
phase or whatever that pre-training
phase
they had all left for the class so there
was but there was a handful of people
that were kind of hanging around and
there was kind of a
there were a couple of people that kind
of felt that stayed in that limbo that
purgatory for way too long
and uh whether you know they they're
like i'm not ready to class up so you
know maybe they wouldn't do as many of
the polls just because you had orders
there
it costs way too much to send you
someplace else so
if you kind of
you know you you could stay in fourth
phase for months
you know maybe even a year but too too
long yeah but your clock doesn't start
until you class up so there's really no
reason to stay in fourth phase and
because you're you're just never going
to go anywhere so
but uh but i show up and there's not a
whole lot of people there and
i get a room and meet my my roommate who
ended up being my swim buddy
great guy
and uh it was like a friday it was the
first day or
first day i had just gotten all my
uniforms and i and they would have a
schedule so
you were around the other the actual
classes but they would meet at morning
for pt and they would do something but
then they'd say okay come back on the
beach and we're just going to do
uh
surf passage and just practice going in
and out of the water there's no time
there's no limit nobody's watching you
it's just just you just go out and do it
or you know we're gonna do a run or go
to the pool or something
so this day they were they're doing surf
passage and this was
i guess it was march
so the waves were pretty good there and
uh
so being from kentucky didn't grow up
around the ocean i wasn't you know surf
or anything i got my ass hammered you
know we had those duck feet that weighed
a ton
and
you know i put them on and get out in
the waves i get knocked down i get up
i'm trying to swim out and i'm trying to
swim over the waves and i'm just getting
pushed pushed right back into the into
the beach
and this happened you know it was the
whole time so the two hours or whatever
you're doing it and i get back to the
room that night and i'm like
how can i be a seal if i can't even get
through the surf zone this is ridiculous
so i talked to my roommate who was i
think he was from california or from a
coastal state
he's like dude don't worry about we'll
go out this weekend i'll teach you and
he did he took me out and taught me how
to dive under the water and kick like
hell and just get through
and uh that was kind of my first
experience of this is this is what a
team does you know when somebody has an
issue
a buddy who has a little bit of
knowledge says hey you know i i can help
you out yeah it's a good thing you
didn't get the introduction of the teams
from me
short stroke in your sit-ups like i did
to that dude
oh man
uh
so
you and i are you and i'm probably what
are you six feet
uh five eleven yeah so i'm five eleven
two cause i remember we got
we got linked up together pretty quick
because we're literally the same height
and
um
that means even in
i don't know if we do we mess with boats
and stuff in fourth phase i don't think
we did if if anything it was just kind
of an introductory thing like here's
here's how you put it on your head
here's how we lift it up but it was
mostly it was just kind of pt type stuff
physical just general training and then
then we roll into
first phase
what'd you think of that
you know i again i was kind of a small
guy but i didn't require a lot of
maintenance
which was nice yeah you were low
maintenance because the big guys i
remember
being on the o course this was right at
the beginning
i don't know if you remember this but we
had a
big guy i know exactly what you're
talking about and he was awesome i mean
and he was a good guy everyone loved him
everyone loved him he was a good runner
he was an awesome swimmer i think he was
a collegiate swimmer
and just but he was you know what you
would think a seal looked like
and we were on the o course and
you know we're all lined up and you
everyone just kind of goes and it wasn't
like a time thing you just
did the did the loop a couple of times
just to practice you know your
techniques and i remember this guy got
to like the third obstacle which was the
highway the high wall so it's a it's a
wall that's probably
12 feet tall and there's a rope on it
and you climb the rope like batman you
know you hold the rope and you put your
feet on the wall you kind of walk up the
wall you and then you get to the top you
flip the other side and you drop down
i i dude i remember that this is one of
the few things i remember from about is
this evolution right here i'm watching
that guy
his forearms gave out his forearms got
out because he couldn't he couldn't pull
himself up the rope
and you know
guys were kind of passing him through
and he spent he spent the whole
evolution on that wall and
we were you know the students that were
done were over there cheering him on the
instructors were cheering him on and
they were like get over the wall get
over the wall
and uh but he never made it over the
wall and they they dropped him
performance drop so oh that was a
performance drop i i think so that now
that yeah yeah it might be what you
remember it might have been a i don't
know if it's a dor if there's a
performance i don't either but again but
that it was kind of another realization
of
you know you don't know who's going to
make it through do you remember how many
people we classed up with
so the number that i remember and i i
don't have any real evidence of this it
was about 116 or some somewhere a little
over a hundred really that's what i
remember more than that but it could be
who knows i don't i don't remember much
i remember losing a guy in the on the
first pt
of the first day
and we were on the grinder um
you know
they're posing us down and we got wet a
couple of times and he turned his ankle
or at least
he did
and uh
and they're like you know of course
yelling i mean it's the first day of
buds and they were yelling at him and he
you know went over and and uh
and quit but
yeah i remember losing and then we we
lost people for performance i think it
was safety you know a couple weeks
before graduation when we're on the
island but
but you know you mentioned at the
opening
about the uh
about the boat crew leader
and i i remember that like it was
yesterday we it was uh we're getting
ready to do
uh night rockport rock portage yeah and
they bring everybody into the
into the classroom to give us the brief
and it was looking bad out there so this
was probably april may you know the
winds were high the waves were going up
and we were just kind of sitting in
there you can hear the wind howling
outside
and one of the instructors comes in he's
like oh man this this is going to be
this is going to be ugly
and this was before they had guys wear
helmets right because it's easier now
but
they all either like you know make sure
you're wearing your head your hats so if
your head smashes against a rock it'll
keep your brains in it'll soak up the
blood
and they're just going on so they come
in give the brief and it's yeah it's
looking bad out bloodbath yeah they're
just they're just talking it up they're
like all right get to your boats so we
all run outside and we had people quit
just bang bang bang
and i remember
this the way i remember
a boat crew leader comes up he goes
who's the next in charge
and it was
one of the other guys
and he hands him his paddle and he goes
i'm falling by the wayside yep that's
the exact quote bro
that's the exact quote that's the exact
quote that that dude said and i remember
you you guys were were good friends i
think i was his roommate
i'm almost positive i was his roommate
and you know we were all at first
foreign come on man you know stay in
there stay in there
at first i go i go what i got to
understand what he was doing like i'm
falling by the wayside what does this
mean like are you picking up a different
position on the boat are you gonna
you're gonna paddle from over here i
didn't know what the [ __ ] he was talking
about
and so i think i literally said like
what are you talking what are you
talking about what are you trying to say
yeah
yeah and
and we were all kind of like
and then jocko turns and like all right
see you later and just walked off
and we're all looking at like
see you later we just walked off and
yeah and uh and the evolution wasn't
that bad it wasn't that bad man it
wasn't that bad he got sucked in he
freaking rang out we also had another
guy that was a stud
that was like all the instructors loved
him he was kind of a jacked guy
he was from the northeast
and i remember he quit and it was like
dang i mean he was a stud he was doing
great at everything it's just a stud and
you're and you're just thinking what is
wrong with these people
which is a really accusatory thing it's
not for everybody the program's not for
everybody i understand that
it is very here's the strange thing
you
you
research about this thing this job you
enlist in the navy for six years of your
life you sign the dotted line for six
years of your life you train you wake up
early you swim you do all these things
and then first night of hell a week you
just got yeah i i was wrong hey i'm out
like that's a lot of investment for zero
return on return on that investment yeah
um
hell week
do you remember did you have any
hallucinations
uh yeah when on the on the long paddles
the uh just kind of seeing stuff in the
water
uh the
some lights and stuff but nothing as bad
as some others yeah some others i saw a
couple traffic lights out in the middle
of the ocean and i knew i was
hallucinating i was thinking oh there's
a traffic light but that's obviously not
right because we're in the middle of the
ocean
we all
one of the clearest memories i have is
one of the guys in our boat crew whose
nickname ended up being chet in the
teams who was my swim buddy he was your
swim buddy he swore
he was swearing saying swear words for
like a half an hour
yeah and i just remember thinking dude
this dude is coming up with some
creative
words right now he was just swearing for
like a half an hour he was so mad about
everything and he was just dropping
f-bombs man it was freaking hilarious
hilarious yeah yeah now he would and
such a great guy again i mean he helped
me in so many ways
uh another thing was i was a good
swimmer but swimming in the open ocean
was was not my thing you know farm boy
from kentucky
so
but he was good at guiding
and
he helped me a lot of times because when
i was guiding i was all over the place
and there were
a couple of times where you know the
instructors were counting down you know
30 29 and we're just
you know
doing everything we can to to make the
time
and uh and again it was largely due to
just my inability to to swim swim
straight
but um
we never failed anything but yeah there
was a couple of times that were closed
yeah i failed to swim
my swim buddy who obviously i'm not
going to say his name so we failed to
swim and it was a swim that a bunch of
pairs failed
so we all lined up now was this
like a time yep it was a time swim
sometime in first phase it wasn't like
uh conditioning where they're like all
right oh you fail no but a lot of us
failed like there was probably a current
or something whatever
so we fail and this particular who is in
our boat crew by the way
and you you'll know who it is but
so we're standing in swim pairs and
they're calling us in the first phase
office to explain why we failed
and this guy this guy we walk in
and the instructors are like
you know why'd you guys fail and no [ __ ]
my swim buddy goes willing can't
guide
and the funny thing was i was actually
i was actually good at guiding and i
wasn't a horrible swimmer
and
i just couldn't i was in a state of
shock and i was like i guess not and
what we ended up doing as a class is we
split up between they gave us
good swimmers so they're like okay you
you know willing you suck and they put
me with another guy and they put the
other guy with another guy well i passed
the next swim he failed the next one
because he was slow but he blamed it on
good old willing over here that was the
first that's like the first uh
ind the first memory i have of somebody
just not taking ownership and how
totally jacked up it was and i was
thinking even the instructors i could
see the instructors
they they didn't look like oh well
what's wrong with you willing they
looked at him like oh you're a you're a
dirtbag
i could feel that from them so yeah
oddly enough
did you have
was there anything that was hard for you
in buds
i wouldn't say
like hard but but again i i didn't win
anything no i didn't lose anything i was
i was right in the middle
uh if there was anything that came
easier to me was just the running just
because i i just spent so many years
running i had and i had the body for it
uh that wasn't an issue i didn't really
get i mean i got cold as as everyone did
uh but
but yeah i you know
for dive phase
um
no issues but i was comfortable in the
water i was already asking you passed
first time yeah dang
i failed
i do remember when we had life saving
and
and i you know i was
trained lifeguard so i felt pretty
comfortable with that
and i got one of the instructors who was
of shorter stature
and
i was like okay well i i should be able
to handle this i don't know if you had a
weight belt on or just whatever but man
he whooped my ass in the pool
and
it was
i think it was right before they started
grading us
and uh i it really kind of shook my
confidence a little bit
and uh but i ended up doing okay but but
uh but yeah i mean sometimes sometimes
you get that you just get the the bad
draw and especially on pool comp uh you
know if you've got a somebody who's kind
of
watching for some you know it's like did
you do 71 sit-ups or
75 yeah i i failed pool comp and i
didn't even go past the first
the first thing where they rip your mask
off he ripped my mask off and he started
just doing he started going up getting
to breath coming back down knock
knocking my regulator out go up get a
breath come back down knock my regulator
so i didn't get a breath and i was down
there for 17 minutes and i just sat
there like kept putting it back in kept
go doing the procedures
and then after 17 minutes he literally i
sat there on my knees
for 17 minutes and all he did was knock
my regulator out come back down knock my
regular out come back down and i kept
putting it back
i'd get like half a breath boom it was
gone again
so and then after 17 minutes he came
back down give me this gave me the
signal to come up
and i come up and i wasn't even stressed
i was like uh so i come up and he goes
you failed you didn't look comfortable
on there and i was like who yeah
instructor
and
anyways i ended up becoming friends with
him later in the teams and he's like oh
yeah i remember this guy i was just
[ __ ] with you and i was like oh great
you know
my life
so
yeah you get messed with sometimes
that's the way it works yeah yeah i
never was a buds instructor i don't you
know know if that's part of the program
or something see how you handle failure
i don't know but uh
it uh
yeah it's it's kind of a kind of a weird
dynamic and
but that school is you know the way it's
run is is phenomenal and i mean it's a
science and they they do they do good
work it's kind of crazy yeah it's a
crazy thing it's a crazy
thing because
you would not think that 80 of the
people that show up to that that have
enlisted in the military that have gone
through screening tests that have
trained that have told their friends and
family i'm gonna be a seal you wouldn't
think that 80
of those people in that category would
quit you wouldn't think it
and they do yeah
it's some crazy times
crazy times all right so
we get done
san clemente how many guys do we lose to
san clemente island not not too many but
there were a couple of guys one in
particular that was in our boat crew oh
yeah that got a safety violation yes and
that's the very guy
that called me out as being the fastest
so i think he was getting tracked the
whole time i do too i think he was
getting tracked because i think they
just thought this guy's not a team
player and we don't want him in the
teams it's interesting yeah i didn't
know that yeah that's the very same way
that makes sense
uh we also lost an officer out there
yeah and he was a really good guy he was
he was
were we in the same
boat crew on the island because they
moved people around uh i'm not sure if
we were i think so but yeah he he was my
officer my
platoon
he wasn't mine so we were different i
had a different one he was mine and i
remember before we went to the island
we uh our
kind of platoon all met at a pizza place
together
and uh
you know he talked about what was coming
up and uh
and we even had our spouses there and
stuff i mean it was it was something
like you would do in in the teams
and
we get out there and they got him on
something it was so stupid it was a
weapons test
yeah not a shoot academic like it's like
an academic weapons test
there was something going on there he
made somebody mad or something like that
i think yeah because i i believe i
talked to him
like soon after that and he kind of
indicated that there was some past on
the officer
side i'm not sure if he was from the
academy or not but he wasn't yeah he
wasn't from the academy yeah there was
something that something there that uh
that didn't work out and it was
unfortunate because
i mean with little time we were with him
i think he would made an awesome officer
that's the that's the
hard part about having
a certain level of subjectivity in the
training which there's les there is less
of it now
yeah there's less of that subjectivity
when we went through it was
it was very subjective and in many cases
that was the right thing because a team
guy instructors looking at a guy saying
i don't really want this guy in a
platoon with me which is the ultimate
test
now there's a great trick that one of
the master chiefs played on the
instructors at one point
one of the master chiefs who you know
but
he he was running buds and he brought
all the instructors into a room and was
said you know hey
all right who thinks you know we should
we should make this a you know make sure
it's as hard as it can be
and set the standards and everyone's
like yeah yeah and so i said okay what
about the runtimes what should we make
it guys are chipping down the run times
chipping down the swim times chipping
down all these things
and then they get done with this new
model of buds and then he pulls out a
stack of records and it's all the
instructor's records
and he and he says
none of you would be in the teams and he
was right you know you can only be so
hard so
the subjectivity i think it's less now i
believe it's less now but it had a
benefit and it had some negatives
because the benefit is if a guy really
didn't block because look you can be a
tough guy you can just be a knuckle
dragger like oh i'm not going to quit
that that does happen guys just not
going to quit they're just tough but
they don't belong in the teams and they
could they would get rid of that guy but
occasionally you get a guy like that
officer who was a good guy but i mean we
did
we spent a lot of time with him and he
was a good guy and for whatever reason
rub somebody the wrong way
and
that was that bye bye yeah
freaking rough hope he went on to do
great things i'm sure he did i'm sure he
did
so you and i both get orders to seal
team one did you request did you request
west coast no so really so that uh you
fill out your dream sheet yeah which i
think is pretty worthless
but it was for you it was my dream all
day long i was like team one baby it was
literally my first choice well it'd be
interesting to see how they
how they did the you know the division
but so my best friend who again i grew
up with yeah both always planned did you
put it in for sdv i did i wanted to go
you're the only person that put it in
front of stevie so on that so i put you
had three choices my first choice i
think i put like still teammate or silty
it was an east coast team but my third
choice i will go to stvs on on the east
coast just because that's where i wanted
to go and i get still team one
that's crazy
yeah that's crazy
i'm sure it was just you know needs of
the navy as i've i've learned throughout
my career that that you will come first
and i'm sure they had numbers that they
needed and
i don't again i don't know how
things got divided because we had almost
half our class go to the east coast it
was kind of half and half our class it
was kind of half and half
almost it almost was like half of us
went to the east coast half as well yeah
guys go to sdv's were you married yet i
was i got married right before butts
so i i uh went home after a school on
that leave
got married and then went to buds then
my wife finished college and then she
moved out to uh to san diego after she
finished what do you think about coming
to san diego
in the beginning
it was
she didn't want to
leave you know the east coast because
all of our family was there and
so she's like all right i'll go to
california but
don't ever ask me to go out of the
country
and uh of course
15 years later we get orders to germany
and she would have left without me
because she wanted to go so bad
she had a total turnaround and um
but uh we we joke about this all the
time because we're still married
yeah 31 years
impressive but uh but yeah yeah it was
she came out to san diego and and being
married in buds was kind of interesting
because
a lot of people think and i i did
you know before i've found out that you
know but it's kind of like boot camp
where you're there all the time but it's
not you know you you have a schedule you
show up for the schedule when you're
done for the day you're done and
weekends you're done so we lived out in
town
and where'd you guys live down in ib
and uh you had a crappy apartment she
had a college friend that came out with
her so
to help with the rent
and uh
but our room
was all guys who lived off base
so
it stayed very clean
because we weren't living in it yeah the
beds were always made floors were always
swept we might come in
and uh and actually uh ty woods was one
of my roommates from uh from benghazi
uh who later died in benghazi and uh but
yeah we because he had lived off base so
all the guys that had
places off base got a room together and
uh
so we didn't have to clean it as much so
you clean i i didn't leave our face
i don't think i left basins like even to
this day
if i can stay at my house i i'll save my
house i don't want to go anywhere yeah
there's nowhere i want to go there's no
one that's like hey you want to go to a
restaurant echo's like hey we're sure
we're i'm having a fight to my house
tonight i'm like cool
enjoy watching them i'll be watching
them too i'm watching myself in my house
i know when i was like okay this is my
barracks i was in 602 whatever that bear
the barracks 602. i'm in barracks cool
i'd stayed there that's all i did was
stay there i don't think i left i don't
think i left base
in first phase
i don't think i maybe did i go to subway
or something possibly but knowledge is
in there like sharpened my knife didn't
have a car didn't have a bike what are
we gonna do i'm gonna sharpen my knife
gonna polish my boots gonna clean my
room i'm gonna hang out with my other
loser roommates that are also young and
just not doing anything and we're just
going to sit around and have fun but
yeah that that idea of that people don't
understand is that buds hey if you want
to when training's over you can go you
can go get drunk if you want to yep
it's almost a test in its own right of
what you're going to do and how you're
going to behave and you'll get rolled up
eventually or that'll be that
uh
so you end up getting orders to seal
team one
did you protest them are you just like
oh no no hey roger that's where they
want me to go and and i mean again it
wasn't like i was the only guy and i was
with 15 16 of my best friends so it's
like all right well we're going here and
did any we all kind of went to team one
right did people go to other teams
yeah so other west coast teams uh a
couple of guys went to five like my uh
right yeah
a couple of guys went to uh stds i
wasn't i'm not sure what coast they were
on but but yeah we had
but they were kind of an anomaly there
was a big grouping a crew of us went to
one yeah a crew of us went to one that
was what happened yeah
uh
when
when we showed up
we didn't even you and i went to comm
school
before we even went through sqt right
yeah so when we showed up at that time
the
training department
which was at the team they had
of course they had to train the platoons
that were getting ready to go overseas
so
they only did sqt so qualification
training at certain times of the year
and you had to wait til you got people
because remember we had people from
other class classes that came after us
that
went through that training together
so
during that time
we all went to departments to work
and
[Music]
before i joined the navy i met a the
only time i ever met
a prior seal
that gave me any decent information
um it was in kentucky i don't remember
how i got connected to him i think it
was through my parents because he had
did something with trucking
and uh he met me for breakfast one
morning so i'm
17 i think at this time and i'm just
asking all the any question that i had
and he just you know he was very
direct frank with me he was uh
you know dispelled a lot of the myths
like killing the puppy and and the uh
literally drowned you yeah yeah all the
all the stupid stuff and
he
he gave me like a couple of pieces of
advice first thing was for um for hell
week how to get through hell week this
was his his
thought
was that
what gets guys the most is they plan
or they they think too far ahead
they're not focused on the now
and
so they'll you know you're getting ready
to do a run or you know getting ready to
do rock portage and you're thinking of
what what's going to happen next week
and you know on the swim that i'm not
very good at
and they just
that gets into this loop
and you just
end up quitting he said don't do that
just think about what what are you doing
right now you got to run what do you
have to do to prepare
get your boots get your you know gear
and and do the run
what's next a swim okay what i need i
need my knife i need my disc so
just just stay on the now
and then when that gets too tough then
just take it you know i'm going to get
to this next hour
and i'm just going to focus on what i'm
doing get through whatever
it is right now get over this obstacle
and then i can move to the next one and
and that's what i did that during oil
week you know it's like what am i doing
right now and hell week is great for
that because you don't have to plan
all you have to do is show up with the
right gear and do what they tell you to
do for me hell week was a relief because
i wasn't worried about failing anything
because i was like hey i know
i'm not quitting and
i wasn't
i had failed to swim like i said because
my
because we had issues and i had failed
one run
because i tried to pace myself
and i'm not a fast runner so i was like
oh you know i've passed whatever it was
three runs at this point so i'm gonna
pace myself on this one and i failed i
barely failed but i failed
so i was always
sweating
failing stuff and so when hell week was
coming
i was like cool i can't fail anything
bring it and i had fun yeah i mean i i
had fun because i knew that i wasn't
gonna quit and i was just
having a good time
so the second piece of advice that it
gave me came
when it was when you get to the team
you need to find the job that nobody
wants
do it do it well
and you'll always have work
so when we showed up at still team one
and we're all kind of going into the
departments
i was like i i want to go into the comms
department and because nobody else
wanted it because carrying the radio was
heavy and
people had this kind of idea that calms
was
just this mysterious magic thing
when when it worked
it was pfm you know pure [ __ ] magic
when it didn't well you know the gods
weren't aligned you know yeah the moon
wasn't aligned that day
and uh and i knew that not to be true
and if i could you know do that job well
then i knew
i would always have a job and and back
then
you know if you weren't in a platoon
they had you in a department
and uh you know like well today it's you
know everybody's a shooter so you just
keep rotating out but back then there
was no guarantee of that and if they had
too many people at the team
then if they didn't need you then you
did you just sat in a department until
something else came
so i wanted to to go into comms
and
[Music]
when we got to the team
there was a billet two billets that
opened up at the east coast
comm school
and the way i remember it
at that time
you know there was this
kind of my belief was there was this
real
east coast west coast rivalry
and none of the older guys at the team
wanted to go to the school because
that's east coast i don't want to go the
east coast we do it better here and uh
and the
i think people in the training were like
you know you can't teach me anything and
we were new guys hadn't didn't even have
our trident yeah or even through sqt
so we're like we'll go
and uh
and sure enough they're like okay cool
and uh yeah and they sent us to uh to
comment school i had stood quarter deck
watch with a
post platoon commander lieutenant
who
we're you know so we this is back we
used to sleep on the quarter deck you
know in that little bunk broom so we
we're hanging out you know whatever we
got pizza for dinner and i i mean this
is literally within being of at the team
for probably a week
and he says you know i'm like
you know freaking i'm ready to rock and
roll i think we're going to nam the
whole nine yards
and you know he he says what you know
what what are your hopes man he's a very
cerebral guy anyways very nice guy he's
like you know what are you what are you
looking to do like i'm looking i want to
go on ops i want to be i'm going to go
out there and he goes hey if you really
want to go on operations
you need to become a comps guy because
no one wants to do it
and yet every operation you want there
100
has to be a comms guy there you don't
necessarily need a sniper you don't
necessarily need a point man you don't
necessarily need a machine gunner a
rigger you don't necessarily need a
rigger you need a comms guy and so if
you want to go on every operation you go
be a comms guy that morning i woke up
really turned over the watch and went
right to the comps department said i
want to be a car i want to be a radio
man
so so there you go that's how i ended up
and i remember there was pushback from
the guy at the east coast that said
we're doing send me two dude guys this
is an advanced course of instruction you
can't send new guys they're going to get
slaughtered out here yeah
and we just said bring it
so
so we show up that was a freaking great
course of instruction it was phenomenal
and you know that was again the start of
our career
and to have that
that skill and
and again when we get back
or got back from from the course
i'm i'm sure that we had some bit of
arrogance about us i know that might
surprise you about chocolate
but uh
but i mean we we
we understood it we
had
the skill down and there was uh nobody
could touch us
and
you'll probably remember the guy who
taught comms and training cell at the
time
he was not a fan
he did he hated me he hated you you
hated me you were quiet enough to be
like go under the radar i was like
that's actually wrong you did it
19 year old jackal was a handful son
because when we were in sqt and he was
doing his comments class
he yeah he was just all over the place
and i remember specifically the zulu
time do you remember that
what
he was trying to explain
in developing a comms plan that all
times are in zulu and why it's in zulu
but his terminology wasn't quite correct
and
he was saying that zulu time is so many
hours
back or something and you were like no
zulu time is over
[Laughter]
and you can see i'm a new guy bro and
you can see it in his face he's getting
kind of red he's like no no no what what
it means because it was something that
had to do with daylight savings time it
changed
and it's it's like it's this off of zulu
and you're like no
subu time
i used to run my life on sulu time
so when we went to that course this is
the cool thing so we show up at this
course we're not seals we're i mean
we're new guys
we don't have our tridents yet we jump
in with a bunch of experienced east
coast guys and
actually there was another there's a
couple guys from team five out there
that had a platoon or some
platoon or two under their belts and we
just
same thing where everyone's live they're
living in town whatever we're living in
the barracks where all we're doing is
saying we have to learn morris code you
and i are like talking to each other in
morris code like freaking c3po and
and r2d2 right uh studying this stuff
we're totally into it we have no i like
people think you graduate from seal
training you have some kind of tactics
for the field we didn't have any of that
we didn't know what we were doing or
equipment or or equipment yeah that's
where we didn't have anything
so the chief
at first he was pissed that we got sent
out there you sent me these two
knucklehead new guys but then he
realized we were freaking fired up and
we want to be like there's not too many
seals that are like hey i want to be a
radio man that's what we literally
wanted to do
so once he realized that
he was kind of like okay but then he
would kind of test us and one of the
tests he did so the that course
uh the the end of the course was a
six or seven day
in the field ftx
and it was around a swamp it's around an
airfield that's a swamp you're in the
middle of a swamp
so this chief that was running the
course
he and he he he goes wait link
and he says hey if you're hardcore
you'll go in the field with nothing but
a poncho and a poncho liner
and i was like what did you say if i'm
hardcore is that what you just said
because trust me i'm joking i'm freaking
hardcore so you're saying poncho in a
poncho liner that's what okay cool yes
i'm hardcore i'm going to feel to the
poncho punch liner what by the way key
component here poncho poncho liner
no ground pad
which is
which is insane did you have a ground
pad no so so you and i are idiots we
have no ground pad we have no sleeping
bag we have no bivvy sack we go with a
poncho and a poncho liner and we are
wearing wool not the smart wool you get
today but like
like world war ii yeah
wwii i think we even went to uh
one of those
gi joes stores or whatever and was
buying
old wool yup to wear
so we go in the field
when we start get when we drop when
we're driving to the field
and now so it's january in virginia
february maybe probably yeah january
january february we're driving to the
field
on our drive
it starts raining
as we start pulling into the area of
operations it turns to sleet
as we're getting out of the vehicles it
turns to snow yeah it's
freezing
and i remember as we got out of the
vehicle and we start you know our patrol
into our first point
we get to uh this little creek or
you know where it actually has water in
it
and uh jacqueline and i look at each
other and chocolate goes to me goes
you know it only sucks the first time
because yeah you get wet once you're wet
you only get wet once you only get wet
once and uh so we just drove right
through it yep it only sucked the first
time that first time lasted seven days
he sucked once for seven straight days
so we end up
so on that course you had we had
communications windows that we had to
make with
stations around the country
so we're setting up these old-school
antennas echo charles this is where you
literally take out pieces of wire
and you measure the wire to the
frequency that you're going to be
communicating on and you hang these
pieces of wire clandestinely in trees
and then you make these communications
window and we had like a communications
window every two to four hours the
entire time
and what happens is if you you're
getting graded the whole time and he
comes out and checks your you know if
you've got like what they call if you're
out camping so if you've got stuff
strewn about and you got your sleeping
bag out and everything's out of your
rucksack
then he's gonna dock you points or he's
gonna send you on e and e or something
like this and if you miss communications
windows then that's points against you
and how strong your comms is that can be
points against your points for you
so what happens with all the other
groups literally every single other
group
they missed some of their calm windows
because it's every two to four hours and
why did they miss their calm windows
because they would fall asleep why would
they fall asleep they fell asleep
because they got it on a ground pad got
into a baby sack in a freaking negative
zero degree uh sleeping bag
and they just would fall asleep
we literally could not sleep we could
not sleep we were we would just stand we
were i remember just sit there looking
at you we're marching in place
by a tree
at two o'clock in the morning three
o'clock in the morning we have every
piece of clothing that we have on we've
got a poncho over us and we're marching
in place trying to stay warm because
we're gonna freeze to death bro we have
we're soaking wet it was freaking
ridiculous no ground pad
we don't miss any calm windows
we we set up great antennas because we
had all this time to set them up because
we weren't sleeping
and we make all of our calm windows we
make good communications on all those
calm windows and we end up as the number
one pair and the number one pair gets
the early extract meaning when everyone
had to stay like
the full day or the extra night or
whatever we get pulled out of the field
early as the number one pair two
freaking meatball new guys
we get pulled out of the field early
and here's a here's an awesome thing and
i don't know if i don't know if you know
this but that chief
called the master chief yeah he called
the master chief of our command and said
hey you sent these two knuckleheads out
there they just graduated the number one
pair in the class they're freaking
squared away you should you should take
care of these two guys they're great
seals which was we weren't even seals
yet yeah so it was really cool obviously
i let it go to my head like hey no one
can tell me anything about calms i'm the
freaking ultimate cops guy
well i mean if you look at it it wasn't
like we were just the right place at the
right time and you know we made a good
decision that was it i mean we knew
we knew our [ __ ] yeah and there was no
one else
at that team at least that could counter
that so yeah i think we were you know
somewhat arrogant but
again that's what we set out to do we we
wanted the hardest job we were going to
do it well and
we never had a problem finding work yeah
that was uh
that was good times
so
then we go into sqt
yeah so we going to sqt when we get back
which we had just been through freaking
hell week i think it might have been
harder than hell week well i came out
worse oh that's right you had
significant trench foot right yeah yeah
to where i for weeks i was down and i
remember
like sitting at home having my feet in
hot or warm epsom salt and just the
pain of that feeling when it when it you
know it comes back to your nerves and
and still today i have nerve damage from
that it's uh when i retired you know you
go through your uh
your medical screening and yeah i still
have uh
uh part of
from that now i've gotten used to it
because it's been been so long but uh
yeah you had a legitimate case in 1991
or 1992 of world war one trench foot
yeah from spending
whatever seven days in the freezing cold
with our feet were wet the entire time
that was another thing we he told us to
wear jungle boots
he was like you wear because you can
wear all these these standards you know
danders and these high-speed boots
they're going to get wet and you're you
know you they're never going to dry out
and i was like roger that so what i wear
jungle boots what'd you wear
and i actually carried that through my
entire career my entire career i almost
wore jungle boots 90 of the time unless
my rule was if there's snow on the
ground in insert during insert i'll wear
something else if there's not snow on
the ground i'm wearing jungle boots and
i did that my whole career because your
feet because jungle boots they dry out
echo trolls so there's little there's
little drainage holes
so they dry out it might take them a few
hours but if you're wearing a pair of
thick insulated boots they are not going
to dry out and so i wore jungle boots
almost my whole career and finally i
started making some modern boots that
were
comparable to yoga boots
so now we go to sqt
uh which was awesome we had some great
instructors in there
great instructors teaching us
the the fundamentals we were kind we we
got
it was almost like our generation of
instructors those guys were like one
degree of separation from vietnam
for the vast majority of our instructors
it was i also think it was important
that
the training was still at the team at
the time so
you know these were people that you were
going to be in a platoon with
and you know there was a lot especially
still team one we have you know kind of
that history of having that ownership
and uh
you know meeting a certain standard and
they they really they really pushed that
and i think that came out in the
training that we got during that time
but yeah these were guys that
had been in for
and had multiple multiple tunes i mean
they just did it over and over and uh
yeah they had quality quality training
it seems
kind of funny now when i look back on it
but there was this thing that they would
say at team one team one it's not just a
number it's an attitude
and they
in fact our seniors oftentimes were kind
of joking when they said that because
you know we also had the nickname was
stalag team one because we had uniform
inspections and haircut inspections and
everything was
like more militant
but i believed it
i mean i was like yeah hey it's not just
number it's an attitude especially young
taco it's all about that like
number one that means something there's
a reason team one of course so i got a
little crazy with that
but the instructors freaking outstanding
um
and and i still
i so much of what i learned
i learned then and i
fast forward a little bit but i always
say like 70 of what i learned in the
teams i learned while we were
instructors at trading cell at seal team
one absolutely we'll get to that um
so
we go through that we go through sqt we
had anything any big high points of sqt
no it was just again we were with all
the guys from
some others
and just quality quality people and
now it was it was a good time the
training was good and you know back to
the stalack one
i mean and i consider i'm sure you do
too i mean we grew up at soul team one
and just what we learned there
set for the rest of the career
set your your work ethic your you know
the way you see things and the the
community as a whole and i'm i'm proud
to have been
at team one and from that period of time
it was yeah it was phenomenal yeah
i think i remember this time
where you you told me you were going on
a trip
and
i think you were going on some kind of a
trip and team five was also going on a
trip and i remember you telling me you
should have seen their palettes like
meaning their aircraft pallets when you
build when you go on a big trip you you
load your your aircraft pallets with all
your gear
and there's a science to it and there's
an art to it too like making all squared
away making it way to write making it
look good and making it look clean so
the air force inspector will pass you i
remember saying man you should have seen
the team five pallets you were disgusted
yeah i mean if it looks like trash it
probably flies like trash
um
we get done with sqt
and you we roll into our first platoons
we're in sister platoons now we had to
be yep because they didn't want to stack
the platoons with
with with both of us so they and this
was a i think a great you know strategic
decision they always had us you and i in
different platoons but i mean we talked
every day and i remember
if i did a comp plan or something that
worked or didn't work we would get
together and debrief about it and uh but
yeah they always kind of kept us kept us
separated
were you the primary comm guy in your
first platoon no i there was a primary
but
you know it was early on like just
just get it done so i had a lot of
leeway right uh but uh because you know
he was had other stuff to do but
um but it was pretty pretty clear who
was making
the uh the comm plans and who was
keeping the gear and uh but uh and then
from then on yeah yeah i i was super
lucky being they i was the primary com
guy in my first platoon pretty awesome a
lot of responsibility for a freaking
meatball new guy
and that's also where i realized hey if
you don't want to be told what to do do
it ahead of anyone being able to tell
you what to do so that was my goal our
platoons had some unique personalities
very very unique
your platoon was pretty savage dude
they uh it it was again an interesting
time and it wasn't
it wasn't like an even
or a like a bell curve it was you're
either a brand new guy or you had
four or five platoons
and there were there was
maybe one but there there was there was
really no in between
and uh
luckily
that i think there was five or six of us
uh new guys new guys that uh there was
at least one or two that had the
spotlight on that so it kept the
spotlight off off the uh
of the others yeah and i was in my low
you know low mode you were like hey i'm
gonna keep my mouth shut i'm gonna do
what i'm told it's gonna make because it
was a scary place in the 90s
at team one as a new guy it was
there was much different there was there
was
there was scenarios i could unfold
really quickly if you were out of line
as a new guy and your platoon had
definitely had some bruisers in it yeah
yeah some bruisers in it studs
freaking legendary freaking 90s team
guys just getting after it
my platoon was a little bit more
uh
a little bit more mellow than that still
i mean i'm great guys but just a little
bit of a different personality the
personality of my first platoon is a
little bit different than the
personality of your first platoon
uh
we end up going on deployment together
we go to guam
um
my platoon got in so much trouble on our
first trip that we didn't do we never
left guam again after my first trip
really yep
we did one trip we got to go on we did
one trip and we got so much trouble
that we never did a trip again they
pulled us off the schedule wow you're
not going there you're not going there
you're not going to there i didn't
remember that yeah so that's why we were
that's why that's why i was sitting in
guam for five months
and how many trips did you go on i think
we did three yeah so you probably did at
least one or two of ours uh that we were
supposed to do we got rotated out we
were a disaster
um the guys like to party i mean i must
say so
uh
got done with that oh i mean what was
your first platoon any any big
leadership lessons learned
no again at the time you just i just did
what i was told and you were even though
or technically with as being a calm guy
you know i was i was
well aware of what i needed to do but
you're still kind of learning how the
community works and you know there's
things in the in the field that that you
know you're still trying to develop and
uh and you know you mentioned the guys
they they were it was a unique
dynamic but they they were still solid
people and uh
they were good mentors and you know they
they worked with you if you if you were
really hey i'm
i'm here to to do this then they were
all about
teaching you and sometimes you know
not the care but the
the the stick but but you you know they
they did get you to where
by the next platoon you were ready to
to be a department head you were ready
to lead and uh and you knew tactically
what you needed to do the
the the
underlying tone that i took away that i
think was instilled in me the most at
seal team one was being professional and
that applied to like hey
when you're in the field you're a
professional and that's what you need to
do you you're squared away you don't
have your crap line all over the place
your gear's squared away you don't have
straps hanging off of everything that
that was the deal
time to shoot you freaking you shoot you
shoot the way you're supposed to shoot
you're not throwing rounds all over the
place
when it's time to make comms you make
freaking calms
and i still have an eval that said made
comps 100 of the time
100 of the time there's no mat there was
no voodoo for for freaking me and gif we
were making freaking calls that's it we
were making freaking calms that's what
was happening
uh yeah but that high level
professionalism yeah and when i was
talking about your platoon had
personalities
they definitely had awesome crazy
personalities but for sure professional
it's the same thing with the guys that
were in my first platoon they were a
little bit more light-hearted but they
were professionals and you didn't want
to mess up you wanted to do a good job
you wanted to learn as much as you could
you wanted to be a good you want to be
known as a as a good operator that's
what you wanted to be known as and so
that's what you did you know
we'd always be all of us our whole new
guy crew
saturday morning be at the team we'd be
working out we'd be fixing gear we'd be
hanging out that i i remember that until
until basically we went on that first
deployment that was what it was i just
remember always being at the team always
being always this is this the way it was
uh after that first platoon
then i
started volunteering for arg platoons on
the ships and you continued doing the
the what we called spec ops platoons
right which was going to
guam basically and then going on
exercises from there how was that next
platoon
i it was it was good you know because
again now you're past the new guy stage
and now people are looking to you to
you know to start being a leader
and uh we had we had good new guys great
new guys and i had
now i'm the department head so
if there was any strains on me before
now those are all gone uh you know we
had we had good officers and it was it
was good but it was still back to guam
and uh spec ops um you know
it was the 90s so you know you did you
did what they asked you to do
a lot of fed but uh the drives
yeah the dry years then then you did
another platoon you got back from that
yep did a third one and um again now i'm
starting to look at okay
i'm i'm ready to be lpo chief right i've
got the comms thing down i'm good with
that now i need to to start moving up
and the problem that we had at that time
was
the
the way the navy worked
is you had that source rating
so you competed against that source
rating to promote
and my source rating was i seem an
interior communications electrician so
my job in the navy was supposed to be
fixing phones
and
navigation equipment on ships which i
had no clue
how to do but
because i was an electrician and i was i
understood how i could look at a
schematic
when i took the test because that's what
you take the test on i could look at the
schematic and go oh yeah well this is
this is a resistor it's probably this
and
you know navy tests are all the same
there's two answers that are totally out
and then there's two that are pretty
close and you just got to choose the
right one so i was good at taking the
test and promoting all the way up to e6
but after that now you're competing
you're still competing to to make chief
but we're all competing against in
different ratings
and
ice semen just was not advancing because
at the time a lot of people that were
doing that job
were
would get out and go work for like a t
or something and but now
uh cellular networks were coming in so
nobody was getting out so the only
people that were advancing were people
who had been in 17 18 years because you
had to build up that time
but then but all my friends who are in
different ratings like i think whole
technician was one you know they were
making rank
because everyone was getting out and
working at the uh at the shipyards but
we're all doing the same job as a seal
but that's not what they're testing
thankfully that that changed and we have
an so rating and uh
and that that's better but at the time
and that that was really weighing on me
on promotion because i was ready to
advance
but it was the navy system that was
keeping me from from doing that
and uh so after the third platoon
and that was our first rotation date
and
we knew that some people had to leave
and uh and some some people would stay
and i think the the course was was going
to stay
but i needed to find another way to kind
of break out and
and at the time because we were
deploying down to
southeast asia
i looked at okay how can i be more of a
of an asset to the team
and in my third platoon who we had a uh
our our platoon chief who made master
chief and you know who i'm talking about
because i think you did a platoon with
him too awesome guy but he was a thai
speaker
and we did a trip to uh to thailand and
i just remember
he
he kind of commanded
everything even though he wasn't
the guy in charge but he spoke the
language
and uh
you know kind of going back to
you know you want to be
an asset
and to be a calm guy you're always going
to go because you have the radio well if
you're a linguist that that too and this
was the the 90s so at the time
uh
the administ i think it was bill clinton
administration they were starting to
normalize relations with vietnam
and
[Music]
we didn't have any vietnamese speakers
at the team i think we had one he was
actually from vietnam
but we had a ton of thai speakers and a
ton of others so
i was like okay here's an opportunity to
you know kind of get a skill
i could have you know they're wanting
people to to rotate so i want to go to
language school for a year
and i want to stay on the west coast so
i want to take a uh an asian language i
end up taking vietnamese but that was an
opportunity to
to be able to come back and uh and i
eventually came back to one but so that
was a one-year school one year yeah it
was
one of the worst
years of my career for sure and it
one because the school and defense
language institute is a phenomenal
school i mean there's there's no other
like it
but you
that's all you do is study how many
hours a day are you in class and how
many hours a day do you have to study so
you know the class was a regular eight
hours it's from nine to whatever
and you take a a break for lunch but
i and
this was one thing i wasn't prepared for
and i probably should have studied
harder in high school should have taken
a language
but
i would get up
first thing in the morning early like
around 4 35 and i would study for an
hour and a half before before school
then i would drive in
go to class
take an extra because i think lunch was
an hour yeah it was like a like an hour
for lunch
but they had to deal with you could
spend 30 minutes one-on-one with an
instructor while they ate so you just
kind of discuss things
and then you know you eat for half an
hour then you start class again finish
the day i would drive straight home
study for another two hours
eat dinner study for another hour and go
to bed i need to do that for a year i
well i did it for about eight months and
it took about eight months to feel
comfortable enough where i could take
you know maybe i didn't study that extra
hour after dinner or something but i
mean they i mean we were learning 50 60
vocabulary words each day
and and this isn't a romance language
you know vietnamese is
you know it's it's you know
completely and utterly foreign yeah and
and it's
a tone language it's tonal so they have
um i remember you telling me about they
have six tones so how you say a word
i think you told me about
rice like rice means rice white eat and
some other things depending it was
something like that so the word i use is
ma that's
when i tell people about tones so you
can say the word ma six different ways
in vietnamese so it's ma
anyway but each of those words means
something different totally different
about how you say it so one means a rice
plant as it it's coming up the water
another means your cheek another way
means your mother another way means a
horse another way means a ghost or a
[ __ ] where you bury people
so if you say that the phrase like de la
ma
you know
if if i'm pointing to a horse obviously
i'm not talking about my mother but if
you say it wrong and someone's just
listening
it has a total different meaning but you
can say de la ma de la ma
and it means something different each
time
so
yeah it's just what took hours of just
listening to to uh you know cassette
tapes
that's what we had at the time and some
people are better at this naturally than
others correct i i would hope so i
wasn't
because the amount of hours to towards
you know if you compared with the grades
i was getting i i was way over working
myself but
but i learned so i learned how to study
was a big one
they actually had somebody who was
getting their phd on on learning styles
or something and they came in and
actually worked with us where we took
like a survey
then she met with us and says okay
you're this type of learning style and
what it taught me is like i was wasting
my time with with uh flash cards
because that's what everybody everyone
was using flash cards dude this is like
this is my my bread and butters flash
cards so what she told me is you are
better off
just getting a blank notebook and just
writing stuff
down over and over kind of like on on
the blackboard you know when you get
punished
because the way i will not make fun of
my comm school instructor so that would
not make fun of a college school
instructor
so i would just listen to conversations
and i would hand write it down i'd you
know run it back
and that helped me
kind of on the listening side
you know understand what i'm hearing and
be able to uh to work it but it was uh
the other bad thing about the bad thing
about dli but challenging thing was the
leadership and i know you have a lot of
different listeners
the intel community
in my opinion are not you know they're
not necessarily leaders they're good at
getting information putting it in
reports i mean that's their job
leadership wasn't quite it
and the uh
the people that ran
the navy side of dli were all
intel people
that were there for like their shore
duty
and most of the students at dli are all
kids right out of high school because
they you know this is
their job
and they score high on the test and they
bring them in
and say hey uh you know you're gonna
you're gonna study arabic and
they're like okay and
you know they would do fine for a while
and if they failed and they would kind
of move them down to an easier language
and if they failed that then you know
they it was to the fleet or whatever
and uh
but the leadership at the school was was
was challenging because they didn't want
to do any of the leadership part of
actually
mentoring and leading
so
they guys like because i was uh
i made e6 while i was there
they kind of pushed it to us like okay
you're the lpo of the asian division
and you know i'm just struggling to
study every day and learn my 60
vocabulary words so i can you know
talk that day
and uh now i got to deal with
you know this person over here who went
out and got drunk last night and you
know was underaged or crashed their car
or
it was just silly little little things
and uh and i'm thinking you know you're
on shore duty should and that's
something you should be doing
but um but it fell to us luckily
we had some good representation there
some officers and senior enlisted that
were going through different languages
and uh they put a stop to a lot of that
and i'll tell you one story the
one of the guys was
he was later our training master chief
okay yeah and uh he was there and uh
i show up so i'm just showing up to dli
coming from team one and uh got my
my whites on i think i was we were
wearing whites at the time you know my
try my whole business and i walk in
and the uh
the lieutenant
that was running the school you know
they they kind of
as you do your check-in
she's like well
yeah i know you're an e6 but uh we have
uh you know we your class doesn't start
for a couple weeks so
we'll just have you work in the master
at arm shack or whatever uh until your
class starts i'm like oh okay so i go
down there and
the person working
in the shack was like an e4
who had never been in the real navy had
been at this school the whole time
and was failing so they
put them in this office to to be the
master at arms or whatever
so i show up again e6 or i was e5 at the
time
and i walk in
and they're like well yeah we're we're
doing some painting of uh some of the
offices so paint cans are over there
just grab a you know grab a can and a
brush and and you can you know work
paint in the office for the next couple
of days i'm like
okay so i walk out and i i
see the uh the master chief and again
he's like oh great another team guy and
i talked to him and i'm like hey uh
what's the deal with
they want me to paint an office for the
next two weeks he goes
no walks into the lieutenant's office
shuts the door comes back out like five
minutes later and says you work for me
for the next two weeks
so that ended that oh good stuff now
when you came back to team one now it's
like
1997 1996 1997 something like that yeah
and you go right into training cell and
that's where i've been now yeah for a
year or something like that so kind of
our core group all went to to training
and so i was i was gone for a year
come back and
i'm kind of you know kind of getting the
layout of uh of what's going on
and uh
i see all you guys and you're like yeah
we're in training cell we're we're
running things right all right
and uh i i'm like you know are there any
straight team one mafia at this point
man we had our hands at everything bro
and i'm looking at that i'm looking at
the platoons i'm like i mean all my
friends are are in training cell and so
and then i think you and i talk
because at the time i think you had
maybe started
the uh the the
comms program yeah i kind of started yes
i had started but i hadn't run like what
i bought the vision was yes but you had
vision of course
so
i think we talked about it like what we
we could do something something big here
and uh i'm like all right i'm all in i'm
all in so yeah i came back
uh the
i think the leadership had just turned
over in training
and we had good people in there the guy
from dli was there and uh so i already
knew he was awesome so i'm like yep
let's let's do this
so
we end up teaching a bunch of different
stuff but
one of the one of the coolest things
that we did was
we launched a comm school for the
communicators at seal team one
and it was a strong it was kind of hard
to get the i don't know if you remember
this the the hardest thing about getting
it actually approved was the amount of
batteries it was going to take the 55 90
batteries that cost 64. each or
something like this and we're gonna have
to outfit
20 guys or whatever it was and our
initial answer was no
no you you can't have money for those
batteries use the rechargeable batteries
which were the ba what were they called
ba 55 something else
and we were like that's that's
unrealistic we'd never carry those but
they only last well and we ended up
fighting and our commanding officer like
we pitched at the commanding officer
he's like all right approved and we got
whatever it was four thousand dollars to
buy enough batteries to run this
exercise
and we set up a freaking crazy
ftx out in the field
and
man
we weighed the guys i remember we
started off by weighing the guys to see
how much equipment they had and and they
averaged average was what in their gear
and equipment 120 pounds at least yeah
so the guys are rolling out on a
seven-day
two-man reconnaissance and we've got how
many teams you think we had
on that first one six or seven
yeah that's uh that sounds about right
yeah yeah it was probably actually it
was probably six because it was probably
two guys per six platoons at team one
and so there you go yeah here we go rock
and roll
and we took those guys out and it was a
ball
buster
yeah
to put it lightly
so
uh i'm sure some of the guys probably
had better terms for it oh dude
it was harsh so we did up in the
southern california mountains we had a
really great target to observe it's a
military target there was military
activity at the target
and that was the key because
i think what you know when we went
through our
course all we had i think we're counting
cars on a road or are watching something
and a lot of the training was you know
you're gonna look watch this missile
site and it was a piece of pvc pipe and
maybe somebody come out once a day and
use but we had an active target where
stuff was going on all the time it was
important because you knew
based on the reports who was actually
doing
the work because there was stuff to
report
yeah it was good and we set up com shots
all over the country and so then the the
the highlight of this first course that
we ran though
was
these there was a one three-man pair
for whatever reason that always happens
in the teams you end up in a three-man
pair for some reason
so there's one three-man pair
and we're monitoring everything we're
not sleeping at all we're we're just not
sleeping for seven days we're like we're
just so freaking fired up
to be running this thing
and
one of the that three-man pair misses a
calm window
and
so we immediately roll out there we're
like freaking starsky and hutch like we
got a missed calm window on freaking
delta iv let's go
so we roll out there
and
and we get to their position and bro we
this is we just knew too much and i
remember
we said like hey you know why weren't
you up on that calm window and they said
something along the lines of like well
we tried but the other station wasn't up
and you and i looked at each other like
because we were monitoring
the station that what the frequency they
were supposed to be called on we were
listening to it yeah and we were close
enough yeah yeah we would have heard it
and regardless yeah like we 100 would
have heard it we didn't hear anything so
we were all out there hey why did you
guys miss that comment they go well we
tried
lie but the other group wasn't up
lie because we got we got columns of the
other group
so i remember you and i looked at each
other we just i don't know if you said
isaac we're like let's separate them
oh we like took a step away like let's
separate them so we separate them and
we're like freaking
uh
who's sure we're like freaking two
sherlock holmes up in this piece right
here
and so i remember i go and and i said
what kind of antennas do you guys set up
and he's like oh we had a long wire and
you're asking i we come back to what
kind of he says he says uh inverted
dipole oh this guy says long wire
they're liars
so we come back over and like all right
um
you guys didn't tell us the truth
and
there's got to be consequences to that
we start making these guys a walk
and
like up hills up the big hills with all
their gear and equipment
and they start walking
and then when they would get to those
points we'd be like call us when you get
there but we'd be waiting for them and
they still had to make their calm
windows along the way that's right
that's right
and
the good the cool thing about this
they they shouldn't have lied and
everything but they were good guys yeah
especially that one character the one
character's like i'm sorry man we should
lie it's my fault we should have lied
and we're like yeah cool
but that's four minutes too late bro
and he was a new guy at the time too
yeah so these guys were just hating life
they they knew they'd screwed up
but
i remember so we so we they'd get to a
spot that we took like on the top of a
mountain
and we'd be waiting for them and they'd
get up there
and be like get out your map
and they you just have to look in their
eyes because get out their map get out
your map means we're going to sign you
another spot so we'd pick
point to another top of another mountain
and they'd be like roger so we did that
to him a few times finally we did one
and we opened up the back of the truck
put the tailgate down
and i remember going um
hey you know go back it was actually go
back to the mountaintop you just came
from
and you could hear like a little bit of
a
and i said or you guys can just put your
gear in the back of the truck and call
it quits
and i remember that one character good
guy's like he's like no no sir no oh he
didn't call me sir but he's like no
jockle it's all right we're going we'll
start walking good to go fill up your
water
fill up your water bottles
um what'd you tell me that guy told you
it was like the hardest training he ever
did well yeah i
talked to him a couple of years ago good
job great guy and uh he's like yeah man
i was still one of the hardest training
you you should actually have him on your
show i think he's still in but uh
yeah it was uh
from his perspective i'm i'm sure he
would
think differently but but uh yeah it was
good
uh
awesome stuff
great training for those calm guys
really and that was you know you and i
were obsessed we realized the importance
of comms we over
indexed the importance of comms to you
and me it was like hey if you can't get
cons you can't get extracted you can't
get fire support which is true yeah it's
true but we were crazy about it
kind of crazy yeah and
passionate maybe that's a better term
yeah
i'm sure some people might call passion
some people call it psychotic
uh but that's that's how it rolls um
the truth hurts but lies hurt more that
was the lesson learned there
so then you end up putting for a
commissioning program right
so when
so this was about the the time that you
left and uh
i was
again i've been e6 for several years now
and i was just i was reading the tea
leaves you know i i would take the
chiefs exam
on
on a job i didn't do didn't know how to
do
and uh
so i thought okay this this isn't if i
gotta wait
another five six years to be chief when
all my friends are
making chief then
then i need to find another job or
another career and you know this is the
time because that was that about 10
years at that time so you're actually
weighing getting out you're thinking
about getting yeah i was like yeah this
is what 99 so there's no wars going on
yeah you've kind of done what you could
do
yeah yeah there was you know if
in hindsight if i knew we were going to
go to war next year i was i would have
not even thought about it but but yeah
at the time i was like okay at 10 years
if i'm if i'm not going to stay then i
need to go and
do something else what do you think you
would have done
uh
i mean i had an electrical background
you know i was
i uh i could
get that job at att you were talking
about
uh
at this time you know i
spoke vietnamese i mean i had
i i knew i could find a job somewhere i
should do something but um or maybe go
back to school and we had the gi bill
so i had i had options
so i go in to talk to uh to the mass
chief same same guy from dli
and because he's now the senior enlisted
for training and uh and i talked and i
go look you know this is my situation
you know i love this job but
i i can't sit as an e6 for another five
years while everyone else is promoting
and just do the same thing
so he's like you know
maybe you should be an officer i'm like
[ __ ] no
and i would go off on this tirade about
you know i you know i'm i'm here to be
yeah
that's i want to do that job you know i
i enlisted i work for a living yeah
and uh no way i was gonna be an officer
and uh
he
he says after
i rant for a while he goes look
and i
and you know this guy's very well spoken
and i
i can't say it like he did because i
just don't remember but in essence it
was he's a gift
everyone here has something to give to
this community
you just need to find the right medium
to do it
and
you know if the enlisted route
isn't working because of outside of of
you know your what you can do i mean
it's a system you're not going to change
that
so maybe you just need to find a
different way and maybe be an officer is
is the right way to go
so i said okay i'll i'll look at at
least consider it
and uh you had just i think
didn't you just get kicked out i got
picked up in
i left
for ocs in 1998 okay and i had applied
in 1997 and didn't get it right and so i
had to try again yeah and i think he had
he had mentioned that so
i looked at your program but there was i
think i was too old you were told
because you were the same age and i
didn't get it my first year and i was
like well i had some other career
choices i was looking at not they were
in the navy i was like okay well i'll go
to a different command
but i'll take one more crack at this to
see if i can get it and i got it the
second time but yeah you would have been
too old to get that program i was too
old so they had another kind of a legacy
program the enlisted commissioning
program that they were kind of phasing
out because they were going over to the
semen admiral
and uh
but it
the way you read it i i actually could
apply for that i was i was right at the
line but i could i could still qualify
so i thought okay i'll give it one
chance
i'll put in a package and we had a guy
from the command who actually i did a
platoon with who just got picked up so i
talked to him about it and he kind of
gave me some advice on on the package
but i said if if i pick up chief this
year regardless of what happens that's
that's the route i'm going
so i put in the package and go through
the whole process and that year they
took 300 packages
and they accepted 150. so i had a 50
chance
i took the chiefs exam that year and i
think
six percent advanced achievement in the
navy so i had a six percent chance of
being
a chief or i had a 50 chance of being an
officer
and i actually got picked up for the
program that year
but the chief results hadn't come out
yet and i was determined again if i got
picked up for chief i would just turn
down the program but uh but i didn't
make chief that year or so
okay this is where i'm going
and then what then what you had to go to
college to get that program get through
that program yeah so the unique thing
about it you had to have prior college
to go
and the benefit and i joined the navy
right out of high school i mean i
graduated on friday that monday i i was
i was gone
but when i went to dli
that was a dli is actually a an
accredited university
and you know they have an accreditation
and while you were there if you took a
couple of extra classes at monterey
peninsula college
you could actually get a
an associate's degree in foreign
language
so
you know you're already in study mode
when when you're there so it's like yeah
easy i'll take a couple extra courses
you know do a lab on a weekend or
something
and so i i did that so i actually had
two years of college
on on my record and that's what i used
to get in because they only gave you you
had to finish
and
well they only gave you two years but
you had to be dumb before 31 and that
was the other problem
i was going to be 31 you had to be
commissioned before you were 31
and i could only i only had like three
semesters
but you know
i've been through dli i knew i could
study yeah i was a calm guy i can do
this
so
you know what's freaking ridiculous the
program i did the program i did i was an
e5 at team one i packed up my [ __ ] i
went to ocs for 13 weeks and then i was
an officer at still team two and that
was the better program it was the freak
it was ridiculous it's the reason that's
why it doesn't exist anymore because it
was too good it was too long i agree
like i they were there i had by the way
i had zero college it was like okay cool
yeah go ahead be an officer now i was
like are you i was kind of looking over
my shoulder like are you serious this is
this happening cool cool right on yeah
it's uh i feel bad you had to go and
you know get your dli done and now you
had to go back to college and get a
degree man well the bat
i guess the
worst part about it now were you
guaranteed to go back to the teams yep i
wasn't god so i had when i accepted
it was and it was part of the interview
process like well what if you don't come
back to the teams because at the time
you know again this is the
90s late 90s
you know they it they didn't have that
that uh that
opening so
now that you say that and here's the
difference
they took 50 people from the entire navy
from my program you know what i'm saying
so like the chances of getting picked up
from my program were
next to nothing because there was
at least at least a thousand other
applications of people i mean that's my
guess that's not an official number but
a lot of people applied for that program
because it was such a good program it
was created and endorsed by the chief of
naval operations like it was a big
program and it was freaking hard to get
picked up so i guess that's why
when you look at it percentage-wise
not too many people got that program
that i got i freaking got lucky
so for me
when yeah by accepting the program
i was
coming out of the community
they let me go to school
and but when i graduated
and got commissioned as an ensign
they could have sent me to you know
to swo school they could just you know
you could be a pilot you could be
whatever and you had to reapply to get
back into the community
which meant i had to take the that pt
test damn you know from the all hands
magazine i don't think it changed that
much
but we had to take that again there was
a couple of other guys uh guys with me
one i saw last night
but uh
we yeah you had you had to reapply you
had to put in your package
and
uh
i remember driving up to dc to meet
the detailer
and not the uniform one but
but the
civilian one that really ran things
and talking to her giving her our
package yeah you know hey
we really want to get back it was me and
my uh my buddy
and uh
and yeah but i mean we had good scores
because i mean
my bachelor's degree
after being at dli was
was a joke and uh i mean it
and when that's your only job
is to go to college because i was still
getting my paycheck not any of the
special pays or anything but i was
getting paid as 36.
they uh yeah that's all you had to do
was was hand in your papers on time
which you know i had done two three
weeks early so
but so we had strong packages we got
picked up and uh picked back up to go
straight in but there was one guy that
was in our custodian that did not are
you serious yeah was he
not was he questionable
he did he did 71 sit-ups
oh
oh yeah one of them huh you called them
out
bro and i so
when i was at ocs
before i left
one of the master chiefs at team one
said hey when you're getting ready to
graduate ocs and you talk to the
detailer as you just described her the
civilian detailer that actually runs
everything he goes when you talk to her
tell her when you want orders tell her
to look in her top left drawer
for your orders and i go
okay roger that master chief
so i'm at ocs i'm whatever three weeks
from graduation we can finally use the
phone room
and we got a square away or worse i call
the office
i said hey ma'am my name is you know
jacob willink and i'm about to graduate
and i was trying to get orders i want to
go to i was hoping to go to team two and
she goes wow yeah she's like starts
going off oh you know what failed
i'm gonna have to look at that and i i
said and then i i listened to her and
she was not sending me there
and then she go and then i said uh
master chief so-and-so i said master
chief someone so told me to ask you to
look in your top left drawer for your
orders for my orders and she goes oh
where do you want to go
and i go team two and she goes okay i'll
cut your orders this afternoon boom done
how's that for some good ol boy network
activity
that's so crazy right
she was powerful powerful powerful so
and she always took care of me and she
took care of me and she took care of all
of my friends yeah all my friends all my
friends she was awesome no she was good
to me too and when uh so when she
when we found out that we were going
we were getting back into the community
she's like all right so where do you
want to go
and before i could even say it's like
anywhere on the east coast
because i was again you know this i was
wanting to go
back out uh to the west coast you know i
speak vietnamese i mean doesn't that
make sense is that because you'd gone to
because you went to college on the east
coast i did because i it was the only
school that was yeah i didn't say that
so i i had to graduate in three
semesters
and i wanted to stay on the west coast
so i applied for
uh ucsd and all the local ones got
accepted to all of them however they all
said you have to do at least two years
two years minimum i guess you know
that's how they get their money i don't
know
so
i was actually at a point where
i didn't find any place that would let
me go for three semesters so i actually
called the uh
the guy in charge of the program your
civilian
and i said look i've tried everything
i just i just can't because you had to
submit like a uh a
degree plan
and i said i i
i'm coming up short i i don't have
anything so
i got to turn it down he goes
just call this guy he's a retired
captain 06 captain
at norfolk state and see what he can do
for you so i'm like all right
call him up
start telling my story
and uh he like stops me halfway goes
look
just send me all your transcripts just
fax them
good old boy little boy network coming
at you once again so i fax him
all you know all my all my paperwork
within 30 minutes he faxes me back
a training program
and they didn't get they said if you can
do it in one semester we'll graduate and
we'll get you commissioned i'm like all
right
so
i turned that in i got accepted and but
yeah we had to move to virginia
to uh to to go to school
and then once i graduated it was uh an
east coast team so when
where were you when september 11th
happened so
i what was your status so i was still at
school and but i was in my last semester
and it was
a couple of a couple of months before
graduation because i graduated in
december
and i remember i was uh at home
working on on a paper and i was
listening to uh to the local radio
station uh
talk radio and
they came over says
we're getting some reports something
happening i got up turn on the tv
and
and that's that's where i was and i
remember that day
i was getting phone calls on my on my
cell phone
from people from all over
that i didn't know
and they were trying to call somebody
else but i guess all the towers were
real screwed up so calls were getting
directed to people that that it wasn't
because they would i'd answer the phones
like is scott there you know they're
they're panicking i'm like you got the
wrong number because no this is scott's
number i'm like sorry i i i don't i
don't know anybody and i got a couple of
those but um
and then like every other team guy you
know i'm look and i already had orders
so i knew what command i was going to by
that point
and uh but i only had a couple of months
left so
i wasn't making calls like get me you
know get me there because i knew i was
going there within a couple of months so
i just had to finish that one semester
graduate get commission and
and yeah that day i got commissioned i
left the university drove straight
from norfolk to virginia beach and
checked in to uh still team four and
then what was your role team for when
you got there
so this was another one of the i found
out that kind of the issues of the
program
that the day you graduate
yes i mean new butter bars ensign
gifford
is and i'm now a day at day one
well all of my everyone at the team all
the officers especially the jos
you know there's they've been in jail
for a year and a half because they had
to you know finish school
go to bus go to budget school go to ask
ut all the items so
i'm behind them technically by a year
and a half even though i've had 12 years
in the community at this point
i'm
to them i'm just day one uh ensign
and so all the platoons are filled and i
show up
and uh you know again this is right
after 9 11 so you know everything's
crazy but things haven't changed enough
yet to
where they start deploying you know
people differently so we're still
sending you know people to the different
theaters
and uh and i show up and of course i
want to get a platoon i'm i'm ready to
go and they're like yeah everything's
filled so uh we're gonna make you the
training officer
and
which i was okay with because having
been in training so i can i can run
training that's that's not hard however
at that time
all the training had been taken away
from the teams and centralized so i was
more of a like an lno yeah from the
command
to the uh to the training department
which again wasn't wasn't bad but
but at that also at that time they
didn't uh
they just do like the unit level
training
but the
training where you train with the people
that you're going to deploy with hadn't
happened or that was still at the team
so that was kind of my focus was coming
up with a good ore
and uh you know that of course at that
time the big thing was the m you know
the
weapons of mass destruction so we had to
come up with stuff where guys were
wearing mop gear and sure all that
craziness but uh so that that was kind
of my uh
my focus during that that uh that first
workup
but then
right before
deployment
one of the jos of the platoon that's
going to afghanistan
gets fired
and
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding where am i
and i i didn't have a job you know when
you deploy because the whole team
deployed i was just going to be an ops
assistant
but
i'm ready to go and so they ended up
putting me in that platoon
as uh as the third o
uh or yeah yeah third o at the time
which again is kind of crazy because um
12 years
and
i think the big learning experience from
that
was
it was tough for a lot of the other jos
because again we're still sending guys
to south america
to
other theaters to you know because we
still had responsibilities there
and here's me who's junior to everybody
and i get the one platoon that's going
to afghanistan and uh so i could
tell in the j.o jungle that
i wasn't their favorite person but you
know again i was
a lot older than most of them and
and their approval wasn't really what i
was looking for
but um but it was it was a
a great opportunity but there were there
were problems there and even inside the
platoon there were
you know some feelings that uh you know
why'd the guy get fired uh i don't
remember i i wasn't really part of that
it was it was something internal i never
really asked you know my
when i showed up to the platoon
my thing was uh you know i'm just here
to to do what i can to make the platoon
better you know we're we're going to
afghanistan and at this time that was
right when iraq was starting up so a lot
of the focus wasn't on afghanistan
everybody was kind of focused on iraq
and uh yeah i'm like i'm i'm here to
help out you let me know how i can do it
but again the hard part and even for me
you know i'm i'm not a one-year
ensign i have 12 years in and i've
done a lot of stuff i've and it was hard
for me at times and this was kind of my
first
being
as an officer and a platoon
i had a lot to learn of you know you're
not
you know the e6
anymore you're wanna learn wanna hear
when i learned that
so i'm at team two i freaking have an
awesome platoon filled with awesome guys
and we're going on a trip and we're
building a pallet
and we already talked about pallet
building today like hey you're gonna
make a squared away pallet so i'm i i'm
down there i'm seeing the pallet being
built
and i'm like hey we need to move this
box over here we need to get to put put
these rigs over here and i start
building the pallet and and my lpo who's
a freaking great guy and a great friend
of mine uh scotty neil navy seal who
unfortunately passed away but he's a he
was freaking great lpo
and
he he looks me and he goes hey sir and i
was like oh damn he goes why don't you
let me do my job when you go do yours
and it was the perfect thing to say to
me and i i just was like he's 100 right
i'm down here
trying to build a pallet these guys this
is this is what they do this is his
domain right the lpo is going to run
that [ __ ] and i was down there stepping
on his toes and i from that point on in
the
the switch went to my head
that if
if i don't need to be giving my input
i'm not going to give it if i don't need
i don't need to prove to anybody that i
know how to build a palette no one cares
they want to build the palette it's
their palette they want to come up with
the with the with the navigation route
and you know what the hardest one
obviously is like oh they want to come
up with a communication plan if it's
going to work if it's a viable plan
we're going with their plan and i'm not
going to interfere with it and that's
the that's the moment the exact moment
in time when scotty neil said to me hey
sir why don't you let me do my job and
you go do yours and i was like roger
that part of me was a little bit
paranoid i think too of like i want to
show everyone that i'm a hard worker
like hey i'm here to move move and and i
would continue to do that throughout my
career of like oh if you got stuff to
move i'll move it and i'll keep my mouth
shut because i know you guys don't want
to hear from me about how to build a
palette about where to how to set up the
range about all that stuff
that's the that's the that's the e-man's
domain yeah and i didn't mess with it
as long as there was viable plans
happening we're going with the with what
the plans are
so true and i had a very similar
experience i think it was even with a
palette as well
and uh i was very fortunate that the lpo
was just so squared away just one of the
best people i've ever worked with still
a very good friend
and uh
but because i was in his squad you know
i i dealt with him quite a bit and we
came up with
a signal that if i was out of my box
so if we were at a meeting he would like
rub his forehead or something
and that was like
okay
shut up and
just
let let things go and uh yeah just
phenomenal guy and and and you need that
because again it's it's hard for
us that had that background to uh
to to uh step back and and learn that
but yeah
well when i had in my second platoon i
had the the
officer that got fired and i had the
legendary
officer
take over and he was super experienced
he was a prior senior chief
he's a prior senior chief and he didn't
put his
he didn't he didn't tell us how to build
pelts he didn't tell us how to do
anything he asked us he put us in charge
he was awesome and as soon as my lpo
said to me hey why don't you go to your
job i was like man
that's what
that's what the best leader that i saw
did he did that for us and i'm going to
do that from now on good little lesson
learned yeah no it was so what was that
deployment like so you're you're pretty
early into afghanistan yes what year was
this like 2003 yes uh yeah so it was it
was it was early but more importantly
again everyone was focused on iraq so we
were
kind of a
like a task unit light so it was mainly
a platoon with some supporting people
some headshed guys
and we weren't really established yet in
uh kind of our operational sense so
we uh you know we were just trying to
find work and we did a lot of special
reconnaissance a lot of driving around
to afghanistan
and non-armored up humvees and with the
doors off it's just too heavy
and
so we did a lot of those missions we did
a couple of direct action
um and it was it was a it was a good
deployment again i learned
a ton
i was with really really good people and
you know we had our issues just like
like everything else but it was a a good
learning experience from that but
the main
leadership things and
the oic and i had
a couple of words sometimes and
and it was
again i think that one because he told
me there was a feeling that
you know i kind of got lucky to be in
this
and i think he made a comment like you
know guys some guys really earned to be
here
and i was thinking what do you think
i've been doing the last 12 years you
know all this you know when when
i was in my first platoon you're still
riding your huffy bike
uh up and down the street so
uh yeah i try not to take it personally
and you know it was a lot of growing for
me too because again it was it was kind
of a strange time but
uh you know we came back from uh that
didn't didn't lose anybody and uh and it
was it was a good first deployment to a
combat zone because we got to shake a
lot of stuff out
and we weren't really driving like you
know like
we were later or you know definitely
what you guys were doing later yeah that
that's a such a nice gentle ramp up and
i had that too uh like even even
literally when i got to baghdad in my
first deployment
my the the
sea who's a freaking like awesome guy
his wife used to say that me and him
were soul mates but we just always got
along like brothers and but he was
already on the ground and so we showed
up and the night we showed up he's like
hey we're getting
mortared from this area take your
platoon out and go check it out and so
we're like i'm like okay cool and
basically he just kind of made it up
just to get us out there shake out the
whatevers get okay look you're in iraq
now get over it it's time and then you
came back and he's like all right cool
now let's start looking at our first
mission but that's and then that whole
deployment was a nice
ramp up of of learning opportunities to
learn going back to your point of like
when someone says
you're lucky to be here i was just
talking about this on the academy
uh training leaders
and
one
it's
such a good and we actually just talked
about this on the underground
uh
just just saying like yeah
yeah i agree
and and
it's so disarming to people when you say
yeah you know i'm 100 lucky to be here
oh absolutely
and
i wish i had that advice well i always
know what i said we all wish we had that
advice you know you're talking to the
guy that was telling the instructor of
our communications course that no it's
zulu time zulu is always zoomed zulu is
always 19 years old that guy was what 35
he was a senior chief
uh he was definitely a chief he's a
chief yeah yeah so he's a teacher i'm
telling a chief
hey listen chief let me tell you how it
is bro jocko's got word to put out son
so yeah we all we all wish we could go
back and maybe freaking check some stuff
but that's that's a good one you know
like hey when somebody tells you
something
and well you nikki it's like okay yeah
absolutely it's disarming it's a good
way to understand what their perspective
is it's a good move it's a hard one to
learn it is because that's a shot right
you're like looking at him literally
thinking yourself are you kidding me
right now it's a total ego thing and i
fell right into it and uh but yeah it's
but you know what was your op tempo like
on that deployment it wasn't uh
not too crazy not to i mean we were
doing like long patrols like week long
you know eight days nine days uh with
resupplies that kind of stuff
so
you know it was tiring on the guys it
wasn't real strong kinetic it was just
long long drives and we'd just drive
around and see what what we could find
and we'd talk you know try to talk to
people try to get an idea and the 2000
the ied threat wasn't heinous yet no no
and and again we were in non up armored
humvees we had the doors off you know so
we could uh easily
engage
and um so yeah that that wasn't uh that
wasn't big at that point
um
so then what'd you get what'd you do
when you got home from that deployment
so i got home i'm like all right
you know now now i can finally do my
aoic slide because that was you know
really what i wanted i wanted to start
at the beginning
so you could you know do a good
mentoring
and
i get back and say hey i'm ready for my
platoon they're like oh you just did it
you just had your aoic slide so it's on
a fit rep yep so um so now you got to
wait another two years because that now
because i'm still behind so my year
group
is still
kind of working their way through uh sqt
at this point and uh but i've already
had my thing so
uh the the new ceo of the command uh
came in and i i talked to him and again
it was like how am i gonna be relevant
so at that time a lot of people were
getting the
uh
going to the army aso schools because
that was so like advanced special
operations stuff right and uh so i'm
like right that's that's what you uh
that what you need then i'll go it and
it was again nobody wanted to do it
because they had to deal with the army
and i knew why
and uh because the the one school was in
bragg for like
three two months three months it was a
long time probably two months
and uh it was exactly four hour drive
from virginia beach to brag
and it was you know one of those regular
schools you do it during the week and
then on the weekend you do whatever i
had to
in the beginning i i would drive home
for the weekend
and then drive back on on sunday but
for class on monday and i had i stopped
driving home
because i knew if i went home i wouldn't
go back because i hated it that bad
and
it was just what part did you hate about
it it's just the way the army ran it you
know it was the kind of protector of the
tab type thing and it wasn't just me
because there were just a couple of navy
guys and it was it was mostly army
all sf guys
and uh and all all great people and and
i got along with with everyone
and uh
but it was
even they were getting frustrated from
the silliness and it was silly and you
know all of us
had you know what 12 13 14 years i mean
these were senior guys and like you know
i still got to prove to you that i get
to be here what kind of stuff were they
making you prove just it was a lot of
stuff was very subjective
and you know they would they would test
you so they would fail you on something
to see how you
how you reacted and some guys were like
screw this i don't need this and they
would just leave
and then
but you know they were just kind of
wanted to test you so you have to do it
again it was a lot of just kind of
administrative kind of stuff that and i
was a class leader which you know so i
had to meet with them every day and you
know they had to tell me how to take out
the trash and all that whatever okay get
some yeah but you know i got through it
and and it was good because the the
community was just it wasn't something
that we were used to
and we didn't really have anybody quali
i think it's better now
but we needed that and uh when
we got
on that next deployment to iraq
it was uh it was somewhat
a benefit to have that that type of
skill
and
the uh so i i had a like a small cell of
mostly chiefs because again all the
platoons were filled but you had uh
guys that
weren't in a platoon
so um
we all
just got trained up and then when we
deployed we kind of got farmed out to
different units
and our
command
had the psd
personal security detachment for the the
the top five
so this is now
this is now 2005. uh yeah yes yeah okay
it was that summer
got it pretty sure got it and uh so we
my team of guys again kind of got farmed
out because the army was kind of running
that at the time
so
i got put into an oda house north
of uh
of baghdad
and for about three months and because
their guy that did that job had to leave
was it on a river
no i i
did some work up there it on the river
it's crazy actually a crazy area an
awesome audi but and and i have to say
that
these guys were phenomenal
to to work with and uh
you know i get asked all the time i'm
sure you do too you know who's better
the
army sf or or seals and i mean obviously
we are but
the uh but but truly i mean these guys
were professional
like
awesome professionals and their
concept
of
was a little bit you know they just did
things a little bit different not better
or worse but
uh
they were just a well
developed uh group of guys and
what
struck me as the
is the most beneficial and what i really
admire them the the leaders the so the
oic and they had a senior enlisted
yeah they only had one officer so
i show up and
you know
they didn't ask for me
you know
or really they needed some help but and
i show up
and i talked to the oic and and uh we're
about the same age and we you know
talked for a little bit
and so they they have a meeting of the
the group of the house so uh they bring
everybody in and
i remember you know they kind of
introduced me to everybody and you know
they made a couple of navy jokes which
was fine
but
then the the senior enlisted who again
just a phenomenal
individual
he goes
so
today
mr gifford is is part of this team
and he is one of us
and they they call themselves the eagles
he goes today he is an eagle and from as
long as he lives in this house
he is an eagle and you will treat him
that way and uh
from from that whole time there i felt
like i was part of the team
and i i you know even though we didn't
go through the same training or anything
i i've they
brought me in and they were just a
phenomenal phenomenal group of guys and
how long were you up there working with
them about three months
what were you doing
so with this new skill set which we'll
say is pretty much
intelligence gathering intelligence
through various methodologies is what
you're doing and you are basically
helping them gather intelligence so i i
was the primary
like report writer so when all the
information came in i did the evaluation
on it write the reports and send it and
send it out the reason that we chose to
to do that by farming guys out was
because of the psd mission
you know they they were really relying
on on intel
heavily because you know they were going
out for
public things and you know when there's
a threat they want to know about it
and
there were all these units scattered
everywhere so we chose certain specific
places that
we figured there was some could be some
pretty hot intel that concern
uh the top five and they want to be able
to get that information right away so by
having kind of a liaison in those houses
if something came up then they could uh
we could get the information to
our guys uh doing the mission
very quickly what were the living
conditions over there all right it was i
it was awesome so we lived in a house
in the middle of
of town and then it was
adjacent usually to a iraqi um
military base and then so there
where like the deep inside perimeter you
had several rings
and
you know at that house we used to get
hit
maybe
at least once a week if not more
and you know we all just go up to the
roof we had stuff everywhere and it was
just you battle until they stopped you
know you weren't moving so
you just kept going
until it was over and uh so yeah you had
everything right by your bed and as soon
as the
alarm went off because we always had
somebody on watch that was
uh
they would send out and everyone would
just go up
and then uh then we would run
you know our operations from there and
then uh and we we did a couple of das i
i did those with with them
and they were good again we went out did
you get a partner force that you were
working with with the iraqis that you're
on base with or were you guys just doing
hits kind of solo we we did have a
partner force but it we didn't really
use them that much they were kind of on
their own i think some of our guys did
some some teaching over there but if we
did something it was it was pretty much
just us and uh so i went to you know
like i would go to the range with the
guys and they would kind of teach me
some of their ttps and
again not better or worse just a little
different uh but total professionals and
uh i was able to
to work with them yeah that three months
and it was it was phenomenal it's one
one of the best uh
best parts of that tour but
even
on on the wide scale just to be able to
work with guys from from that uh
that oda was yeah it was phenomenal
so then what did so you're only there
for three months what'd you do when you
got done with that so after three months
they they were switching out so they
were kind of off cycle from us so they
had about you know the same amount
length of deployments but they rotated
out that way all sf wasn't rotating out
at the same time
so when uh
they left the new oda that took over
that house
had everybody they needed
uh and
apparently chris gifford wasn't part of
yeah there wasn't uh
it was like we appreciate it but we're
good kind of thing and i i think it was
you know kind of more of a headshed
thing and
you know there's there's no way to force
you know no reason to force it on them
you know i kind of explained to them you
know this is what we're looking for
if you get this information please just
send it to these people
so i got brought back and um
the
there were two teams deployed at that
time so one from the east coast and one
from the west coast the east coast team
was doing the pds the west coast was
doing
more
connect type stuff
so they needed somebody
i think their ops officer
had to go back
or something but they needed a spot
filled so
my command asked if i would just go down
and work there for a month
and uh so i i did that
and i was just in the op shop or in in
the talk
running ops
getting all the uh you know the briefs
in making sure and then while they were
outside the wire
make sure we were monitoring the uh the
operating picture and everything
and uh that's when your old roommate was
uh was down there oh right on and uh
and
yeah awesome yeah it was awesome because
you know now it's
him team one guy
him got to do missions man together
really yeah and there was like a weird
confluence of events that happened for a
short period of time and we were like
out in the middle of iraq together just
doing opposite it was it was pretty
freaking cool man yeah he uh i did we
did one mission uh together it was
it was kind of a circus but
it was a target that was like right
outside
the gate and i mean you could almost see
it if you looked over the wall from from
the uh
from the compound you could see the the
target i mean it was it was pretty close
and for some reason
people came out of the woodwork to go on
this op so we had
like officers
and chiefs oh you mean straps i thought
you're talking about enemy personnel
coming out of the woodwork i'm like no
here we go it's like no no
hangers galore we had a lot of people
who
needed to experience
to outside the wire
and so they were going to be on this
thing and uh they're all looking at the
con ops like hey it's only it's only
1200 yards away let's let's get on that
one yeah and uh so
we're you know the op we get out there
and it's just a clown show because
people are running everywhere so i look
over
at our uh friend and he looks at me goes
come with me
so we go to like this
uh
barrier position you know we're kind of
on the edge as a uh as a you know
blocking position because we're away
from everybody we're like we're gonna
sit this one out we're gonna sit right
here until all this is over
and uh
you know it was a dry hole or whatever
but it was uh yeah it was yeah it's
funny he's he's like a real life sam
elliott with his attitude definitely
just like well we're not doing that you
know just like just a freaking classic
and then and so so you were done with
that but that's still you sell it more
on the deployment right so a couple of
months left i go back to the psd mission
and
we we just help out you know we still
have liaisons to uh some of the outside
units of course all the
ogas and all that so i spent two months
just kind of bouncing around and just
helping out and ops there just to try to
get everything out i don't think i did
any more missions or anything most of
that was that first three months so it
was just and then you know of course
right before you leave now all the
rewards all the awards have to be
written and all the you know fit reps
need to be done so
i uh i was i was part of that uh you got
your absurd crew
[Laughter]
and then what'd you do after that so we
got back
uh from that deployment
and uh and i'm still
not up with my uh my year group
so
i talked to the the co and
and
either he recommended or but he's like
why don't you go to germany for a couple
years they you can do
the ceo had been in germany before oh
yeah
you know who he is yeah he's like
freaking awesome one of the top yeah
friends awesome yeah yeah definitely one
of the top five but he uh he's like you
know you should go out there you'll
enjoy it and
and i remember he told me
he goes if you live on base
i will come out there and punch you
because he's like you need to get out in
town
live amongst the uh
the populace the populous and experience
living overseas like you should i went
to his house when he was living overseas
in germany
and it was absolutely freaking epic i
wish i had taken pictures i wish i knew
the name of the village of the house
because it's still there it was like one
of these postcard
villages and he had this crazy like
old house that was completely like
gutted and modernized inside
it was freaking very german yeah it was
freaking badass yeah so him and and by
the way like everything that guy does is
like all dialed in yeah i remember i was
going to his house and he's like hey you
need to wear a shirt i'm like bro i
don't like them i go i'm wearing a shirt
he's like no a shirt like a like an
actual human shirt not a freaking
jiu-jitsu t-shirt you idiot i was like i
was like i don't have any shirts and he
goes all right come and he opens up his
closet his closet is like
a room
and he's got no kidding hanging up
just
buttoned down whatever really nice
shirts in the color of like the rainbow
like starting with what is it red orange
yellow green blue purple
with with freaking nine shirts of red
and it goes all the way through
and i'm like bro are you freaking james
bond or what i don't even have i shirt
much less 49 shirts of varying colors
but yeah that was all in this completely
dialed house overlooking this green lush
valley it was crazy beautiful yeah yeah
and again a phenomenal person and
and
for what he's done for the community and
yeah just just a great guy so he
convinced me this would be a good good
place to go
and uh and he was right it was probably
my one of my best tours
because you you move your family out
there and you know you're you're part of
not not the war necessarily because it's
it's not in that ao but you know you're
still doing really good good stuff and
at that time you know africa
was really starting to pick up
so i was able to uh
uh be there as that was kind of starting
and again with my my background and
you know all these
these uh intel type type schools it was
it was a very good fit so
um i worked in the uh as as a task
officer there at the uh at the uh unit
uh and we were moving guys down to
africa so we would send guys you know
they would
basically check into the unit in germany
and then move straight to africa for
four to six months some sometimes
and you know working through embassies
so that was my
my experience of you know starting to to
deal how the state department works and
how all these other good times oh
oh yeah
yeah that was uh
you know when you when you retire and
you know what you don't want to do
that that was one of i i knew i did not
want to uh state department wasn't in my
uh
but they're good people they do they do
a hard job they really do
so you you wrap up that's one of the
what's that a two-year billet it's a
two-year billet and i was there exactly
two years we left
almost i mean exactly two years and uh
and now it must be time for your platoon
commander tour because you already
knocked out your aos yep so my
everything now i'm aligned with with the
rest of my your group so uh so i get
sent to uh team 10
to do a platoon commander
and
the
because i came from
i think because i came from germany and
i understood how
the africa comm and uconn work i can see
where this is going that they put me in
that task unit and again i was fine with
that because i'm here to support the
effort
nobody wants to do it then you know i
don't have anybody breathing down my
neck trying to get my spot so i i'm
finally getting my platoon commander and
i'm just stoked about it
so i show up to team 10 and i get in the
task unit and i
kind of get an indication
pretty soon that
the the
all the guys that just came back
were in
i i think was iraq
yeah i think they they came in from iraq
it was afghanistan but they just come
back they had a really good
deployment
high
energy intensive
and uh
but now they're on the yukon and we had
a bunch of you know new guys who never
hadn't deployed yet and they're on ucom
and they're seeing all their friends
getting ready to
go to afghanistan iraq because i think
we're we're still sending people to both
so yeah there was that kind of idea that
you know what
that's where we want to be and i i get
that but uh as our
our
mutual chief used to say uh you know
orders aren't invitations they're
they're orders and this is what you're
given and you need to
it's it's our responsibility as the
leadership to make sure our guys are
ready for that and that's that's what i
was doing but
there was a lot of
you know you know if we if we do really
well then you know we'll get move over
to here somebody will get fired and you
know we'll be able to take that mission
and again there's always that chance but
there's also the chance you're going to
do what they
what you were assigning what you were
assigned to do so we really need to to
focus on that and there there was a big
um
i guess kind of rub
between you know me and and the
leadership and especially being in
germany for two years i i saw platoons
come out all the time
and you could tell the ones that were
ready to do the mission and
accepting and they did a great job and
then the ones that are like hey we're
just sitting here until we get the word
that we're going in
and guess what the word never comes
you know i mean again they may take ones
or two because somebody gets hurt but
you know we have a mission too here so
there there was a big
leadership challenge on my side is you
know i need to keep the guys motivated
interested in this job and i would tell
them you know there's there's good stuff
going on there's there's really
important stuff
and uh and for the most part i think the
guys accepted that some some didn't but
uh but yeah that that's
it's a tough
tough thing to to work through
i remember one thing that always
always stuck in my mind there was a a
master chief faculty
so master chief faculty um
who died in 2017 but he was a huge had a
big impact on all of us a team one at
the time
but i remember him telling me a story
that there was a vietnam guy that had
come home that had done like a pretty
heroic deployment in vietnam
and that guy was facts like lpo
and they're out in the desert doing
their desert warfare training
and that guy who is like the combat vet
he was
like they're out on patrol and he had
his like rifle up over his shoulder and
just kind of like walking like it didn't
matter
and and he just and he was he i think he
was the platoon chief
and you could see the just
disappointment as faq was telling me
this story
and it was one of those things that
again he probably told me that when i
was 22 or 23 i never forgot
that fact not only
of hey
don't be the guy that's like been there
done that i don't need to be fired up
for training anymore but also what an
impact that has on everybody else
and
you don't want to be like that then fast
forward
however many years i was now at trade at
west coast trade and i had a guy
that's a great guy
and
he was in he was in ramadi with me as a
new guy and now he's in his second
platoon and we're out at the mount
facility
and
like you know we're training's hard and
kicking ass and blah blah
and
i i talked to him about whatever but i
remember him saying to me
he says uh i'm kind of getting burnt out
and this was during mount training in
his second platoon and i'm like i just i
go hey bro you remember when you and i
were in a work up together and he goes
yeah and i go that was my seventh workup
and he was like he just got that look on
his face and he goes roger that because
i was fired up in my seventh freaking
time to go let's rock and roll like
every taking everything seriously and
that's just what you want to do so
that
infection can spread
um
and it's a hard pill to swallow team
guys want to go to combat that's what
they want to do and
when they don't get the chance it hurts
and
but like you said you got to pick it up
okay this is what we're doing
let's do it to the best of our ability
and and the only thing you can do is
just keep going on deployments
like the god of war
is gonna do what he's gonna do and if
hopefully you get blessed by him and if
that happens great and if it doesn't
happen
keep working because he's watching
that's the way i look at it yeah
and
you and you saw it you know guys would
uh
you know kind of have to get through
that that rotation but then the next one
they they go back or you know they get
another shot at uh combat and you know
we all knew eventually it was going to
calm down anyway uh but nobody knows
when and you don't want to miss it
and i really felt for the new guys
because you know all they're seeing is
their friends that are going and they
didn't do anything wrong and that was
really a
a big kind of complaint that i had about
how it was perceived as you know we're
waiting for you know if they get into
trouble then we get into that spot it's
like well so are we here because we got
in trouble you know how how do we end up
are we hoping that our teammates are
screwed up yeah because that's not a
good attitude so we get that spot so
i oh my thing was look again the war is
bigger than just
what's going on in in centcom
we have a mission to do it's a good
mission
it has value
and uh and you know thinking back you
know maybe i could have done better
on certain things uh
but uh but yeah i mean it was it was
what it was and we actually had a good
deployment
i took a a crew
of uh of people
to uh to africa and we were there for
several months and we we did good stuff
and
and uh you know
i like to think that we you know moved
the needle hopefully a little bit but uh
but it was yeah
you know i think and i think
most people that were with us
kind of got that after a while and then
what'd you do when you got home from
that deployment so i got home and um
so i'm looking at tu
commander and uh
but i i didn't want to stay at team 10
for
different reasons but
but those positions were already filled
so it's like okay
i need to to move on and so now i'm i'm
caught up to my year group
but it's still a little bit different
because i've had all these other
experiences and because of a lot of the
victim of my own success
a lot of the schools i went to kind of
put me on a little bit of a different
track which was fine
and uh
so i uh i ended up taking a uh
an ops tour at uh another command there
in virginia
and which was great and again great
experiences and and everything uh but
it's it's kind of where i was
when that was coming to an end
they uh i met with the detailer so now
i'm at 21 years 21 and a half years
and uh i met with the detailer and i
wanted to
take over east coast training the ceo of
that kind of what you did but on the
east coast and i knew the guy that had
the position good friend
and uh i talked to him about it he's
like oh yeah he would do great here and
it
it lined up
and uh so i talked to the detailer and
he goes uh
you you need more joint time
i'm like oh okay
which means you know you get orders to
probably tampa
and you move your family there and at
least at the time then you deploy
overseas for a year or so and write
reports for others
and uh
and work on your jmpe and you know all
that and your your family sits there and
because it's a pcs move
and at the time you know my wife had a
great job in virginia she was working
for the the governor's office and uh
you know she wasn't really wanting to
move so i was like okay you know maybe i
can
do kind of a
bachelor kind of thing
and uh but then i thought you know it's
i've had 21 years then i think maybe
this is
time that i find something else and uh i
was very fortunate the navy was great to
me i got to do everything that i wanted
to do i had a great career
and i
i felt like i had closure
and i don't you know put it on the
detailer i mean he's he's trying to fill
these bullets and for an officer at 10
11 years that is a great move and you
know that's going to set you up for
uh your exo tour and you know
probably another staff job and co
but yeah i wasn't an officer at 12 years
i was an officer at 21 22 years
and uh i just i just felt it was it was
time to uh
to retire and uh and try something else
and so
i went home and
talked to my wife about it and she's
like i was like yeah i'm thinking about
retiring she's like okay whatever
go in monday drop my uh
put my paperwork to uh to retire and
went back and like okay i did she goes
what'd you do like i retired she goes
you did what
it's like yeah yeah
i did it how long was it between when
you dropped your papers and when you
actually retired uh probably about six
months or so you know you have to i had
a lot of you know leave built up that i
need to get rid of and
i had made
lieutenant commander but because i
wasn't doing the full time they
they didn't commit or go to that next
step and then i just retired as a as a
lieutenant oh those savages well you
know they're like you know you have to
do another three years and honestly i
did the math yeah and going from 03e
to 04 is not that big of a jump than
going from a regular 03 especially when
you have you know 20 some years
and the math i think i would have gotten
maybe an extra
100 bucks on my retirement and it just
wasn't worth another three years i felt
like that one you know i could do
something else
so how was the transition what'd you do
next
well so it was a lot harder than i
thought it would be uh because you know
again this
we grew up in the sil teams and we all i
mean that's that's that's what we knew
that's what we did and uh
even even to this day i tell people i
still have dreams that i'm still in
uniform
and uh you know i'm at some command
somewhere and i'm talking to
to people but i'm i'm still somebody
just called because one of the guys got
in trouble yeah like i always have guys
god someone got arrested
like here we go i gotta go gank somebody
out of jail whatever
so
so it was you know you have to have a
new focus and uh you know a new mission
and uh so my thing was i i want to learn
about business i've
been in government since i was 18 19
and
you know i've been in leadership
positions and i i think you would agree
with the leadership's not different
there may be some different terms but
it's it's all the same but there's other
things about business that i didn't
really understand like what is marketing
and what is uh
you know social media was a big you know
was starting to be a big thing and you
know at that time we couldn't even have
any accounts on social media and i i
think i think it's changed now i think
it's a little bit better
because it kind of hurts guys getting
out that don't have that presence
because that that's how a lot of
business is done now on
on linkedin and stuff
so
i felt i i need to learn business i need
to get
get more informed on that and
i still had half of my gi bill left so i
thought you know i could go to grad
school but
i i still want to learn a little bit
more about how it runs first so so i
make sure if i go to grad school for a
business degree that's really what i
want to do so
i looked for just a way to get into
business
so one thing i had a friend who a pilot
friend that got out kind of the same
time he was starting a consulting
company and he asked me about coming on
as a
as kind of like a 1099 contractor excuse
me
so
yeah that's that's fine uh you know i'll
work with you and we'll do that
and as i was doing my uh tran you know
the transition classes the uh what they
call it the they call it tap i didn't do
it yeah i didn't do any of it so i did
tap i said later yeah it was it was
mostly a uh
i want i want to say it's a waste of
time because it is it had some value to
it but they had like this entrepreneur
class yeah which was an hour it was
during your lunch hour so instead of you
ate your lunch at a table and somebody
talked about it so they said
if you want to start a business just
find something you like and start a
business
so i'm thinking what what do i like to
do what you know what would be fun i
knew i did not want to do government so
i didn't want to work for
any of the alphabet soup i didn't want
to do um
you know stay on at any of the commands
or you know work work as a as a gs i
just want to do something totally
different real business
and i thought you know
i love music i've been playing music
all my life i'm going to join a band
somehow we missed this whole story what
freaking music did you play i i played
upright bass
well actually when i was at like team
one i was i played saxophone that's
right i remember that you played soccer
and i would bring it on the trip
altogether now i remember that yeah i
forgot about that and blowed up that sax
and i was not that good i was actually
i remember that yeah yeah i was i was
not good and i played you know through
high school and
and uh but i was never
really good enough to to do it
but i always liked the bass it was
always something that i really enjoyed
did you play it where did you start oh
so you just liked it yeah okay but i had
enough
music background that that i could uh i
could figure
out so i just bought one
started learning how to play you say
bass are you talking bass guitar are you
talking stand-up bass no so at that time
it was electric okay basically uh yeah
bass guitar and uh
and for some reason it just
it just came
like it was natural easier than
vietnamese apparently very very much so
and uh so i kind of took some private
lessons and uh and yeah i just kind of
took to it
and then after doing that for a while
i uh
as i was getting out
trying to find bands there was the the
market was
was pretty heavy with bass players it's
you know probably
a lot of uh guitar players that don't
play that well play bass yeah i'm not
sure if that's true but that's what they
told me so you know i need to find how
to be how to stand out so i was like you
know i'm going to learn how to play
upright bass because nobody wants to do
it it's a big instrument you have to
have a car or a truck drifting a van
and it's fretless so you know it just
scares people but i'm going to learn it
so i bought one how much does it how
much is the standard base cost like for
your starter model that you get so i i
knew this is what i wanted to do so i
didn't really i kind of
started the starter and got a nice
kind of pro model a uh ingle heart
and um so it was about 2000 around 2000
that's it yeah dang bro and uh that's
actually well it's way cheaper than i
thought it was going to be but you know
it's a plywood it's not like a carved
you know 200 year old i have got
electric guitars that
are
way more than that yeah oh absolutely
more than that a ridiculous amount of
money because i'm stupid
but this you know it's an it's it's a
new one it's not a classic but it it
plays really well and uh so i worked on
that so when they don't have a fret how
do you know where to hold down
so there i do have markers on the side
uh it's like like the dots that are on a
guitar it's the same and uh but you you
have to listen and and it really forced
me to
listen to what the rest of the band is
doing and make sure i'm i'm you know got
the right tone
and uh yeah i just i worked on it like i
took six months of just
how many hours a day oh
two three
hours i would take a break and go back
to it and
uh yeah just worked on it so you mean
five to six hours a day
um
not that much probably yeah about two or
three hours but you're retired every
year when you're retired well no i was
i was still kind of uh you're wrapping
up your wrapping up and and going
through uh
terminal leave three three to some three
or four hours of base a day yeah and and
then
when i felt comfortable i started
looking for uh for bands to play in so i
go on you know where else would you go
but
craigslist yeah there you go
and uh just typed in upright bass and
sure enough uh this guy posted that he
was doing an acoustic blues thing and he
was looking for an upright bass and it's
like yeah there's only one you got the
job well so i called him up and uh
or messaged him or whatever and he said
you know show up to this open mic night
he learned to play in front of a real
live audience and
he he didn't tell me what we were going
to play or anything and uh
so i showed up and he's like all right
you know we're playing in this key
and i i was all over the place i mean i
was i was nervous this was it wasn't my
first time playing live but you know
i was just trying to follow what was
going on yeah because you played saks
live in 8th grade at the 8th grade
freaking student council reading
it wasn't that bad but uh
but yeah i i
played a couple of songs i was like yeah
that that really sucked and uh
afterwards he goes okay yeah let's let's
meet next week and and do another three
i'm like okay
and by that time now i knew kind of what
he was looking for and uh
we we did it and and then we're like
yeah let's start a band
brought in a a friend of mine that was a
drummer
and uh eventually a sax player and we
created the band and my intent again was
not really to be a musician
it or an artist really and i don't
really consider myself an artist i'm
artistic and i can
i understand you know how to do it but
i wanted to run the business so i wanted
to you know manage the books i wanted to
work on the marketing i wanted to learn
how the
uh
how the social media worked and how that
you know worked into getting us gigs
and uh then we got into recording and
writing and i helped you know write uh
some of the songs and we recorded a
couple of albums so we could sell
because that was a big thing when when
you were gigging
you know it's it's great to get that
that uh you know that money for the
night but if you have merch right merch
get the merch out there then you know we
we saw things go up and we could show
i could show each year
you know we were making more money and
we were doing uh doing better how often
are you gigging
so you know the first year probably
about 30 or so gigs
but by the third year i mean we were
touring so
i would do a two week so now you're out
of the navy completely yeah and you're
going on tour in your blues band playing
stand-up bass yep and uh herbie d and
the danger men is the uh are you still
are you still around
no so i'll get to that in a minute but
the um
so by the third year we're playing
probably 180 gigs
making money making money yeah getting
playing how big of shows clubs
i mean we would get a couple of
festivals we would get uh you know
mostly bars you know that that kind of
scene what do you make a night in the
bar
uh it depends on on where you are but
you know four 400 bucks 500 bucks and
how many people are in the band uh four
yeah so from a business perspective yeah
i mean but we're thinking to try
something else no no not at all so
it makes you really look at the the
business model and
because all businesses
have the same all successful businesses
have the same uh
concept you got to make it for a dime
you got to sell it for a dollar you got
to make it habit for me
if you don't do that you're going to go
out of business now you can supplement
it with outs outside income but
eventually it'll fold
you got to make it for a dime sell it
for a dollar and make it habit did you
make that up right there or no
i learned it when i was uh in in my mba
program no one taught me that by the way
that was basically my mba and and those
those three sentences that that was two
years at grad school
but um
but it makes you especially in a in a
venture like that it really makes you
look at your cost you know are you
really making it for a dime or are you
spending 90 cents and of course the
numbers are arbitrary but
if if you're if you're not then how do
you cut that down so
as we were touring you know in the
beginning we were getting hotel rooms of
course we were all staying in the same
room because you know there were four
guys
but eventually we're like okay how can
we cut that down so we uh like one of
the things we got on uh
uh couch surfing have you heard of this
um yes i have so we when i was 19. yeah
exactly well we had a band profile
as uh
uh
for couchsurfing and as we were as i was
making the tour i would say okay we're
going to be in this town
we would submit you know hey this four
piece band is is coming to town could we
stay at your house and surprisingly a
lot of people uh let us do it and it's
it's free it's free it's free
and uh and of course we would we would
try to do special stuff so we of course
give him a cd or a t-shirt or something
and uh
and if we were there for a day or two
we'd break out the instruments in their
living room and just give them a little
concert and it was yeah it was it was
great and what was really nice about it
is because we stayed with them we told
them where we were playing that night
they would usually come out and bring
some friends so that would uh you know
butts and seats that's that's a big part
of it
so yeah make it for a dime you got to
get your costs down and uh and we
learned you know like
buy your water not at a gas station buy
it at walmart before you go because it's
cheaper yeah and all these little things
to get the price down
and then you look at are you selling it
for a dollar you are you
really getting the the top price and you
don't set the price the market sets the
price you know supply and demand
and uh so that's what you know we're
focusing on where can we get the best
bang for our buck
you know if we play at a um
at a uh
a festival or something you know the
focus isn't on
the money you get to play the focus is
on the merge
so
having the guys actually
push the merch you know put the cds in
your hand as you go around and talk to
people because they see it in your hand
they want to buy it and you don't just
sit back and wait for them to come to
you you got to get out so are you you
know making that price and is there
enough of a profit margin there that the
business is actually going to to survive
and then the most important part as you
know you got to make it habit for me if
somebody just watches you once and
they're like hey that was great
and they don't follow you then how are
you going to sell them you know the new
album when it comes out or you know your
your new
uh
you know the new song or whatever you
you've got to get that that that fan you
know down the
the funnel
to uh to get them from interested to
fan to real fanatic of you know the
super fan or they're gonna buy your
stuff as soon as it comes out
um
so that's what i learned during that
time you know how how do you actually
physically
do that
and so we did it for four years and uh
had was that your job for four years yes
so i was doing a little bit of the
consulting on the side and there were
other like 1099 type jobs that i was
doing from here to there but you know
again i was very fortunate that i
married up so my wife was making good
money
uh we don't have any kids so you know
i'm not putting anyone through college
uh and i have a good retirement so i was
able to do that full time so what
happened
so at the end well it's like any
business you know you have that arc and
uh there comes a point where you gotta
pivot or perish and uh
we have been playing kind of the same
material
for how many albums did you make two
well one ep and one lp
and i watched a couple of your songs on
youtube yeah i thought it was pretty
cool the guitarist
i think this was like a thing right you
had that there's a song where he's
playing a guitar that only has three
strings yeah ggb is what we call it yeah
that was pretty cool and you think okay
well he's got some like the white
stripes he's got some constraints around
what he can do and it's going to make
him kind of push a little bit i thought
that was pretty pretty cool it is and
and that was you know kind of the you
got to break away from the humming and
strumming you know the the normal stuff
you got to keep updating especially in
the entertainment world because there's
so much competing
with your attention
and uh so after about four years we we
needed to kind of change some things but
uh
the the lead guy was you know he was
kind of comfortable where he was and and
we could have kind of
gone uh you know a little bit further
but uh but the sax player wanted to do
some other stuff so he he left
and um we tried to bring in some other
people and then i was like you know this
is the time to make a difference we got
to
totally change because if we try to keep
doing the same thing we're going to
start losing people and that's what
happened we we didn't really change
enough drastically that we started to
lose fans and
by that point
i've been out of the navy been retired
for about five years for yeah about four
years
and
i had enough of a grasp of okay this is
the things i need to work on
that i was like okay i'm going back to
grad school
so um
the i still played a little bit on the
side we did some some duo stuff but now
i was i was focused on going back to uh
grad school for my mba that's why i did
and how was that program
it was good i did it at old dominion
university there
because it was close you know it was uh
easy to to to get back
a lot of people in that area went to odu
so you know we had you know planned to
stay there for the long term so it
it it made sense
and uh you know my the gi bill covered
it so
you know the cost was low
a dime and the the return was hopefully
a dollar
and uh and it was good so it um
yeah and did you do anything with that
degree
so yes so i uh once i got
actually while i was in school uh i had
talked to a couple of business owners
that needed someone to help do kind of
due diligence on some uh some business
stuff so it was small companies
that were expanding and looking to to do
some different things
and and i actually still work for them
today but um
they would so i i would
you know do like the the analysis on it
you know is this uh the right thing to
do
uh they're a developer so they would buy
property
and then they would uh say okay what
business can we put on here to make make
money and then we'll turn it over so i
would do kind of the analysis of you
know if we do this you and you take out
a loan
here's all your initial costs if you can
keep your you know fixed variable cost
all that then you can make a profit over
a certain period of years and then they
would say okay let's let's do it so uh
so yeah more of a kind of a
business analysis
yeah
kind of kind of work and
it's it's it's good work and when you
actually see something
uh one one of the projects we we did and
it
made great money and uh so i got to see
all that develop and and
so yeah it was it was really interesting
especially to be able to
kind of say this is what i think is
happening and then you look at how close
it actually did it's not perfect but uh
but it was good it was a really
it's a good thing and does that bring us
up to present day yeah so uh well so
when i was in in grad school uh my wife
got uh
diagnosed with breast cancer
and uh
yeah
that was it was good
being out
of the military although you know the
teams were great about that stuff but
because i was home every day
it was uh
good that i could have i could be there
and kind of work because it took like
two years to go through it from time she
was diagnosed
she had three or four um
surgeries
and then the chemo and then the
recovery from all that took about took
about two years
and um so i was home for all that i'm
still going to school but i could i
could manage it because you know most of
the stuff was uh was at home
and um so
she
went through that and uh
when
we
kind of got through that it was and
still in the recovery stage
we kind of got into a rut of
because she just didn't have any energy
so we're staying at home all the time
watching tv just you know eating
three meals a day or whatever
and just wasn't a lot of activity and at
one point i was like you know we we need
to break this cycle
and so we bought a uh a small
16 foot camper
and uh i was like we're you know we
talked about it says we we need to at
least once a month just get out of the
house we didn't have a tv in it it was
you know just just a nice uh it was an
airstream uh base camp okay and uh we're
like we just need to get out of the
house at least once a month and just
kind of get back even even if we just
walk around a little bit or and there
was a campground right there in virginia
so we did that for about two years as
she was recovering
just going out just getting in
into nature and just you know trying to
get
get past that and uh after doing that
for two years we're like why aren't we
doing this all the time
so uh we decided that uh
about this was about 15 months ago we
said hey let's just let's just sell our
house and get rid of all the extra cars
and the extra furniture and stuff we
have laying around let's get we'll get a
bigger camper because
16 feet is not that's small enough to
live how big is your new one 30 we have
a 30 foot air stream yeah
and so we traded that in
got the uh 30-foot solar place uh it was
a good time for the market
and uh
so yeah for the past 15 months we've
just been touring around
north america just uh
going
from place to place
trying to hit a lot of the the national
parks and you know america is just such
such a beautiful
place and uh
you know growing up in the navy we
traveled all over the place but
never really got to see a lot of the u.s
even on training trips you don't really
get to see much so yeah that's what
we've been doing for the past 50 months
i still she retired totally after her
chemo she
lost a lot of a lot of that that drive
so we decided you know
why don't you take some time off
and um i still do part-time work it's
all remote
they send me emails when they need stuff
to do sometimes i take a business trip
or you know i'll fly someplace and come
back but yeah we've just been been doing
that and uh seeing people like
opportunity to be here and
to use one of the
big benefits but
and you see any end in sight
no not right now just gonna keep rolling
just keep doing it uh every place we go
we we say hey would you know would we
come back here to live
and uh
you know if we there's some some places
we really like uh but what's the top of
the list right now uh we really like
denver colorado they have a they have a
really good blue scene so so i i have my
upright base with me takes up half your
freaking vehicle it does take up a lot
but
i have like my little space over by the
bed i can keep anything i want and
that's that's my music room
and uh but we uh yeah when we go to
these places i look up blues jams and
show up and and get to play with some
phenomenal people and uh yeah it's
it's just part of the just traveling
around meeting people and
seeing really friends and family i i got
to see
some family in texas that some on her
side that she'd never or i'd never met
before and uh we've been married over 30
years
uh friends team you know guys from the
team that now live in all kinds of
places and
you know we stay connected and say hey
i'm going to be in from this time if you
got time i'd love to see if not you know
i understand and
and uh so yeah it's been awesome it's
been awesome and you're tracking this
whole thing on the gram on instagram
yeah my my wife runs most of that it's
uh
taking leave underscore rv
and she you know post every day because
you know how important you got it
for social media you you got to be
consistent are you playing any base
riffs on your instagram yes i think that
people are gonna want to hear that yeah
she uh she records it live and then you
know post it later but yeah when we go
to these jams i i'm up there playing so
sure it's uh
that's outstanding pri hey probably a
good place to wrap it up echo charles
yes sir do you have any questions yes
sir i do so you ran back let's go back
to high school or yeah
do you do uh cross-country damn you've
been saving this question for free in
two hours and 45 minutes that's correct
my school didn't have cross country i
think some of the other
districts did
but
my my school was very
somewhat in an urban area so we had
track and most most of the guys were
sprinters so uh
the uh
so we didn't
have cross country but we had
long distance on the track was just you
know going eight circles
but cross country would have been your
jam yeah i would have loved to do it and
of course i ran a lot outside of uh just
track but uh but yeah like today
uh
another thing i try to do as we as we
travel
i i look for great runs you know run
running running places and i've been
kicking around a uh a youtube video
because i carry a camera with me
and i kind of film little parts of the
run
and then when i get back i uh of course
upload all that and then put together
these four to five minute videos of you
know this is
all kind of the data of the run you know
this is how far it is this is the
elevation you know is it a lot of hills
is it straight what kind of a turf is it
um you know what where do you park you
know here's the address you want to use
to get to a parking area is there
support
is there going to be a bathroom there or
or what
and
so i've i've gotten about 30 runs
done
with with the raw material i just
started kind of putting them together
i've got four completed
and i've got my process down to
about four hours
so the first one took about
a couple of days because i had to figure
out the format that's like echoes based
on making videos
so now yeah i can get
five six minute video done in about four
to five hours so you know again it's
make it for a dime sell it for a dollar
if it takes me
a couple weeks to do one video it's
because you got to be consistent as you
know you got to post
consistently to
to get a good following would you say
that you're uh as far as what you'd
prefer as far as runs go do you prefer
the two mile one mile or 880 or 800
meter yeah so the half mile is not a
distance run i don't know
that's a sprint yeah i mean the guys
that are doing that are sprinting
and
i don't know why
it was like this but i remember at the
track meets like the first run was the
two mile then it was the one mile then
the last one was an 880 so i've already
run
two races and i'm i'm more out and now
you got to sprint the 880 so i i like
the distance running yeah and the runs i
do now are anywhere from five to 12
miles long what's your fastest mile
back in the day so when i was running uh
back in the day
when i when i was running marathons then
i could
get down to a good
um
around seven minutes seven little over
seven minutes for a marathon for four
yeah for for a marathon what about like
in when you're competing in track or
whatever yeah
that got down i think uh about a six and
a half somewhere around there but uh i'm
not doing that now now
i'm more along for the ride
i want to look at the things and yeah
hey talking about youtube one last thing
i want to talk about or just at least
explain uh you made a really cool video
about your grandfather yes that was a
pretty cool that people might want to
check out yeah i you know i attribute
that to uh really to you jocko it you
know listen to this podcast one of my
favorite things is when you have
guys from you know world war ii korea
the you know the vietnam and
just the stories that they tell and
everybody's got a story
and uh
when i when i hear that
i remember my my grandfather actually
both of them
both served in world war ii
excuse me
and
but my my one grandfather
was was just a very introverted
and he was in the army he was in the the
mechanized in in tanks
and uh he went over as a replacement for
uh
for the uh
it was the 81st
tank battalion
and uh but he never talked about it
when when i was growing up i would spend
summers working on the farm with him and
uh he never mentioned it and at that
time you know i didn't know what to ask
for or you know you know tell me about
the the war and uh
but he never but it wasn't like it's
just me he'd never talked about with his
kids or
you know his family it was just a part
of his life that was kind of in the past
and
and uh just never talked about it so
and he passed away in the in the early
90s
when a couple of about a year or so ago
my aunt brought me his
like his old photo albums from that that
time
and it also had all of his military
paperwork in it which
you know you think of our
field jackets are pretty thick back then
it was like a page or two i mean there
wasn't wasn't much at all like go to war
cool your home yeah that's it exactly
and you know
so
because of my my time i was able to look
at these and and kind of understand all
right so he was at this unit at this
time and he was actually in the fourth
cave back when they had horses damn so
you know to think about that that time
of when your main asset was a horse i
you know this this animal that has its
own personality and
you know you think of of what we drive
today
and uh but but that you know that's
that's part of your main thing so
uh so i was able to come up with a
timeline of where he was what units he
was in then i spent
some time just reading books on it so
finding books about that unit overall
reading it reading about that time
reading about the the operations to kind
of get a better idea of
what he did or what he may have done
because i i don't know for sure i never
he never told me
but i was able especially on the
internet i was able to find some
after-action like their monthly
reporting from that unit
when he was uh when he was over in
uh in germany as they were pushing to
the rhine
and uh and of course oh i've written
plenty of after-action reports you can
kind of read between the lines
sometimes but it had great data
and i was able to kind of
take all of his pictures that he had in
his albums
digitize them and then
go kind of walk through the story using
all these external sources and say okay
this is
you know where he would have been during
this time this is what happened during
that time so he was probably on this
uh this
uh calvary march or he was probably in
the tanks when they
got hit on this so i kind of found the
the one day that he probably was in
combat for the first time you know where
they first took casualties
and again i don't know for sure but uh
but i was able to kind of create a
timeline
so i created a video of all his pictures
so when i'm
doing the voice over
and i'm telling the stories
they're showing pictures of kind of that
period of time and so you kind of get an
idea and i totally just did it for my
family because they didn't have
really any stories from him and um
yeah i said kind of a deadline to have
it by veterans day i missed it by a
little bit but i want to do it before
the holidays so when they were with
their kids they could watch it with them
and kind of understand who their
grandfather was and where he came from
and uh so yeah that's uh that's what you
what's the youtube channel that that's
on so it's on my personal channel but uh
his name is everett wiese i think the
name of the uh the
the file or the the video is you know
corporal evert uh whis so if you spell
whis
w e i s s w i e s e okay so yeah it's
german but it's uh completely w-i-e-s
yeah everett
yeah w-i-e-s-e but uh yeah i mean uh one
of our mutual friends sent that to me
and told me to check it out it's very
cool um
awesome stuff if there's one thing i
could say that
i found
that i don't
like about this is or the nomad
lifestyle the nomad yeah is uh the
vagabond um
it's it's
because you're traveling around so much
you're moving you know we move every uh
two weeks to a month
you really lose that
kind of connection to a community
and uh for example like for jiu jitsu
for the
before we did this i was training i'll
be it i was you know white belt no
stripes
but uh and if i could i give a shout out
to coastal bjj they're in virginia beach
phenomenal gym they were awesome you
know guy white hair coming in
at 50 they they uh
they took really really good care of me
nestor and the guys down there just just
awesome guys
and um so i i was i was training with
them and
and
it was it was that that community but by
doing this you got to leave that and i
and i talked to him before i left i was
like you know what do you think you know
can i just go to another gym and and
start working and he said yes but what i
found especially with cobit it's tough
to
kind of show up
for just a couple weeks
and you know nobody
knows where you've been and you know i
think a lot of gyms especially like this
because it's such close contact that you
know they kind of stay in their own
and uh and it's it's tough to uh to
kind of be part of that community
and uh i think we're going to change
that as as we go through this
lifestyle we're finding that uh
the first year and a half we we've been
jumping around so much
that we kind of need to home base a
little bit more so we have a property
down in florida
and
so our plan is for the winners we'll
probably be there
and spend about five six months there
and then be kind of part of that
community and then for the summer pick a
place like i think this year we're gonna
go all the way up to maine so we're
gonna hit uh those areas and then maybe
the next year go out maybe back out to
the west coast like we did this year
just we're in maine to see people
farmington maine
go to the origin factory you know the
deal you do you got people to train jiu
jitsu with come to the camp we have camp
in august okay it's freaking awesome
actually i might be there yeah during
that come on up man okay it's it's it's
awesome i mean it's so cool there's
several hundred people there
from all over the world
to train jiu-jitsu hang out
it's it's great yeah again i'm white
belt there's all kinds of white belts
there that's no factor all right no
factor at all come and get it all right
that'd be freaking legit i'll look for
those dates right
any other closing thoughts man yeah
thanks to my wife that
supports all of this uh
this
this crazy
thing that we do and uh she's just
i mean she's my best friend and we've
been married coming up on 31 years and
just no one else that i'd want to do
that
do this with so really appreciate her
right oh man well
thanks for coming on man thanks for uh
thanks for sharing your stories thanks
for sharing your lessons
thanks for your service to the country
to the navy to the teams and uh thanks
for being someone i'll always be able to
call friend man
appreciate it thank you
all right so
chris
he's gone he stepped out uh it
you you may have heard people say
there's no standard day
in the seal teams yeah that's absolutely
true you don't have hey this is just a
normal day but but what i think this
highlights is there's just no kind of
standard career there's so many
different directions things can go
that
you're just gonna have a different
experience and what's cool is you can
have some control over that experience
you have you get you you have the
capability of adjusting i mean you look
at
gif and i
very you know came in at the same time
we're in the same buzz class we kind of
like the same
same we're on the same path and yet you
know he's speaking vietnamese we we both
became radio men but he's speaking
vietnamese just all these different
things happen he ends up like doing the
the the advanced special operation stuff
just it's just different things happen
and you just get different experiences
so it's that to me
is a benefit to
joining the military
is and
i can only really say this with 100
certainty about the seal teams because
that's where i spent my time
but most of the military
everyone i talk to it's the same thing
you have it's like a choose your own
adventure book
the chances that somebody else chooses
the same adventure as you is very small
yeah so
awesome to talk to chris
and and hear
and hear his
because because
he's a friend this is the other that's
crazy thing about the seal teams like
your friends come and go and you may not
see a guy for
like when i saw him downstairs i don't
think i've seen him for probably
15 years
15 years we we
and we he he hit me up like god is my
number whatever and he's like hey hey
jock i'm in town like oh cool you want
to come hang out you want to be on the
podcast oh yeah that'd be awesome let's
do it all the time so just but no no
like well how have you been no because
it's a shared you have this shared
common background yeah and then with
that shared common background your
friends you're like cool
i have friends i don't talk to if i saw
him tomorrow be like hey well you know
no factor like no factor that's the
knowing
me i
there's no hey you didn't call me no one
expects you to call me don't expect me
to call you i'm not calling you you're
not gonna call me cool but if you need
something call me call me you don't have
to call me you don't have to prep call
me you don't have to keep you have to
send me birthday cards whatever
um you need me cool i'll show up or you
want to you got you're in town give me a
shout we'll go roll we'll see what's up
yeah you
it does go to show too how like it's
almost like if you put it into
perspective where you have people with
such different backgrounds and then they
kind of can converge on this
navy seal journey they get washed up and
filtered out and then they get kind of
spit out into their you know common
interest for sure and common goals but
in such different ways like if you talk
to you know you say like navy seals
don't have a stereotype or they you
think they have a stereotype i think
they do what they don't but they don't
yeah this is like a really good example
because a man you know i'm talking to
him he's like a
super nice kind of introverted person
and then now talk to you you're like no
way that they were like
[ __ ] pods in the team like it doesn't
make sense and have the exact difference
and have the exact same job yeah hung
out and did stuff together
and then so
like i'm trying to imagine you know like
every time everyone talks like when they
tell their story i always try to kind of
put myself like i wonder how they were
you know like what they look like i see
them in front of me now but what did
they look like the young version you
know what gift looked like
he looked exactly like that man he
looked exactly the same just
darker hair probably he had darker hair
but he looked the same you know there's
almost the same build
i mean i
i'm i'm bigger than i would like when we
went through buds when we started buzz i
was 174 you know i'm 230 right now he
probably weighs somewhere in the
neighborhood well
i don't know what he waiting buds but he
looks about the same yeah you know and
sure does he have a couple more wrinkles
whatever we all do
but looks about the same yeah so you
imagine him like just functioning you
know i can't imagine him yelling at
nobody to me is he's just like this
super friendly person but i'm sure he
was like
getting after the way everyone else was
it's weird that contrast is really weird
it's fun interesting it is uh good stuff
man good stuff oh it's
always good to talk to your old friends
and see where they're at see what
they're up to and maybe maybe there's a
chance they're playing stand-up bass in
a blues band
what bra every
the actual i'll say this in a second
what i did kind of what did hit me at
one point you know when you're talking
about um
when someone
one of your superiors was like if you're
really hardcore you're gonna go with no
no ground pad or whatever all you're
gonna bring is a poncho and a poncho
liner yeah so and you just found the
worst advice ever well
or was it or well yeah in a way it was
like a it was it fulfilled itself right
as a thing the no ground pad is a
problem by the way
after that like i never go in the field
without a ground pad i never go in the
field without a
wool beanie and i did have a wool beanie
but that saved me and i never go in the
field without my
gore-tex jacket because worst case
scenario you put on a gore-tex jacket a
beanie man and a ground pad you're going
to be able to like last a lot longer
with a lot more comfort you if you don't
have those things you're screwed so you
learned your lesson lesson was learned
was was it
that experience
that that made you ground pad 100 okay
so to me what was funny mean good and
that's good for sure but
what struck me the most what stood out
is that you know who you're like um your
watch back to the future
yeah okay now yeah i mean i remember i
know the movie but i can't say i know
the plot so
because i'm not a freaking dork
marty mcfly right the main guy michael j
fox yeah
his weakness was if you call him chicken
he'll do the dumbest stuff if all you
got to do is call him chicken that's
like a theme throughout all the
you know that in fact like later on
that's like why he like ruins oh
someone's questions might be in heart
yeah you're the exact same you're marty
mcfly but instead of chicken it's uh
freaking hardcore yeah well not hardcore
sorry yeah i would say especially when i
was
well no you're still like that you still
like that true
yeah if in fact now you're smarter
though i think i'm assuming but so like
if i were to be like hey
do this if you're hardcore like you
would do this right something that maybe
you didn't want to do or you said no to
or something like that if i said it that
straightforward you'd you'd know what
i'm doing and you'd figure it out and be
like hey i'm not going to fall for that
but if i just hinted at it if you use
the indirect approach indirect approach
maybe took a couple of days to maybe you
know like plant seeds and stuff like
that oh i think i could get you fully to
do some stuff i don't know what there's
nothing wrong with getting people to do
stuff i like it i appreciate it a little
bit of peer pressure in a positive way
let's go with it you know
have i ever told you about the cliff on
quite um on shipwreck speech
no actually i think i'm you know what
not i'm gonna i'm gonna retract what i
was about to i was about to say i could
get you to jump off that cliff but yeah
you'd probably you'd probably jump off
that cliff
yeah it's nice
that's scary how many feet is it it's
not it's put this way it's high but not
super high so is it over 100 feet no no
no okay it was like okay so the last
time i jumped was the last time i went
and i hadn't jumped for like a long time
probably like eight years maybe it's
like when you're young you jump it's fun
it's a little bit of a swim maybe 100
meters swim back give me an estimate on
the height uh 30
35 maybe put it this way i went to jump
throw that up
with me i know i know that's what i'm
saying but i'm saying if no if you
haven't jumped there
it's
it's like it can be intimidated and
people jump off there because they see
other people because everyone on the
beach can see you jump the cliff kind of
wraps around and
the beach is literally like a like a
audience yeah perfect like spot sure
so when you jump everyone watches you
right so what this is tulsa used to do
that tells you to jump off that [ __ ]
when she was a water woman
she just put the cape on
back hi sure this i'm quiet by the way
so
when you go up there it does two things
one it makes you want to like jump when
you see other people say oh that's fun
that'll be an adventure right right you
go
and but another thing that it does is
when you go up there and you sit at the
edge everyone's watching so you can't
turn back and walk down because you can
be like oh you're the guy who walked
you're going yeah you're going so we
went i went with my 15 year old nephew
and he was like i want to do it i want
to do it this time so i'm like cool
and he jumps but before we jump there's
these there were these people up there
they didn't live there so they're like
oh you guys gonna jump
and we're like yeah you're like okay
kind of like it was a bad idea
so i was like she's like oh our friend
is still in the hospital because he
broke his back yesterday jumping off
so i was like dang
so it's high enough to break your back
but it depends on who you are it also
depends on
what you hit i mean this person that
broke their back hit the bottom is it
not deep so they're not breaking their
back from just a regular jump if they're
a normal person at 35 feet bro that's
there's some other there's some other
elements into this story that we're
hearing here's what he uh they said he
was 50 years old
okay i'm 50 years old i'm not breaking
my back jumping no i i believe 100
you're not breaking your back when you
but you're not the average 50 years old
eight-year-old person and if you land a
certain way like oh yeah you can break
your back i think and another kind he
broke his back and he was like
done he he like you know had a fractured
one of his vertebrae in this way he's in
the hospital for more than a day though
so
well weird things can happen when it
comes to injuries that's true you're
going to take that into account
don't want to be talking too much smack
over here plus you got to be careful but
in your case i just call you not
hardcore and you'll do anything
yeah well everyone thanks for listening
thanks for hanging out with uh good old
gif gif and me if you want to help us
out with supporting what we're doing
check out jackofuel.com we got some we
got some tasty goodness on there which
is a weird thing you say first thing
people think about when they think of
supplements they're not generally
thinking like oh tasty
sometimes they even don't think tasty
the first thing i said was tasty why
because because monk it's a front runner
because molk is a front runner it's a
front runner in food to take into your
body and and enjoy that process that's
true cool man they're gonna help
remember the uh remember the freaking
protein shakes back in the day yeah they
were so bad i was on a arg platoon on a
ship
and we had
the
the latest and greatest
and everyone had it and it was so it
tasted so bad it was vanilla i remember
i used to have to hold my nose
because i was on the train right we're
doing we're doing this stuff we're
trying to get you act eating i would
hold my nose and do it like i'm doing a
shot of tequila
so that's how that's not what we want no
have a good taste or remember the old
school freaking mega mask five million
or whatever you know the one in the big
dog food bag or whatever that tasted
good but i think it had like boatloads
of like sugar yeah
technically had more protein or whatever
well they were also like hey this is for
gaining mass yeah so we're literally
just gonna give you sugar
fat protein just whatever we're just
gonna throw it in there make it taste
good hey more power to you if you're a
if you're a hard gainer remember that
back in the day you got the hard gainer
coming in hot yeah and then what's the
two three body types right mesomorph
ectomorph what's the other one endo
endomorph yeah right there you go so
they'd have those little graphs you know
maybe is that a real thing now i have no
idea i think it is a thing
but i don't know what determines that
thing oh yeah because i don't know if it
what
you know what let's face it there's some
truth to it because there's some dudes
that i know that would just eat pizzas
and whatever and they're lean yep that's
true so they might be the hard gainer
yeah and then some people doesn't matter
they lift or not they're kind of jacked
you know i've known people like that
yeah
uh what's and i know some people that
work all out like crazy yeah and they
don't look like it and they can even be
strong
and
even be fast but they still look like
kind of dumpy yeah that is so i guess
the thing is a thing yeah so we got to
watch out for that one
yeah that's true i literally know
someone like immediately comes to mind
for every single one of those that's
interesting
all right well you got to watch out for
that of course so know your body type
right um also speaking of taste good the
energy drinks healthy energy drinks too
but which is a rare thing very rare kind
of a unique thing get some of those and
you can get this stuff at jackalful.com
you can get it wah-wah get the drinks at
wawa you can get it you can get all the
stuff at vitamin shop as well so check
that out also if you need some jiu-jitsu
gear which you probably do go to
originusa.com and what's cool is we
started with jiu-jitsu gear but now
we're making just straight gear for your
life jeans
t-shirts
hoodies
boots whatever you need we got it so
check some of that out the the jeans and
i don't know why these ones struck me so
hard or whatever it's the the that new
the new jeans that they're coming out
with they're like green or something
one that pete said the next one is going
to be camo the work they're work pants
yeah yeah
i don't know if i do actually i'm not
sure which one i know you're talking
about i'm pretty sure they don't do the
work that's required
yeah they got any padding in the knee
let's face it that padding's not going
to get any any action no use for my work
that's for damp sure but nonetheless
for people who do do work these are both
functional and aesthetic man i'm looking
at them and i want them you know just
for the look alone and then i know
they're probably more functional than
they look good so it's saying a lot
and get yourself some gear and by the
way support an american company that's
rebuilding american manufacturing and
helping american communities and workers
that's what we're about
that's what because if we learn about
that guess what we'll be doing hiring
some
slave labor overseas
in china to make everything for us and
get make a little bit more profit make a
little bit more probably wait we can
stuff a little bit more money in our
pockets over here
to rip it out of the hearts of the
american worker we're not doing that
that's not what we're doing so
originusa.com go check it out there you
go it's true also when you're when
you're uh in the mood to represent
on this path hey look we're we're
capable which kind of reminds me you
know how like and some some of the
guests will have this where they'll talk
about like their background or whatever
and then you know they went through this
they went through that they already had
this certification or this you know
it like makes you think man those sort
of and there's a lot of them available
by the way certification yeah like gif
mentioned uh he
was a paddy diver yeah yeah before he
even joined the navy maybe yeah and he
wasn't even really um i never dove
on scuba gear until i was in the navy
yeah see and that's one that i always
was like man that'd be a cool interest
because i grew up right did you dive
yeah i grew up doing scuba diving no
never so snorkeling free diving we call
it yeah
wait wasn't who was it um micah right
we're talking about friday michael yeah
and we didn't go into that he was some
kind of world-class uh bro
my younger brother yeah yata charles
yeah he is heavy not so much in moria's
kids and all that stuff now but he's
heavy into freediving spearfishing all
this stuff really good too one of his
friends i know who michael was i don't
know that's why i want to kind of ask
him
yeah man he and one of his friends
actually i think still holds the record
of the deepest free dive if i'm not
mistaken i could be mistaken but i'm
pretty sure he showed me the videos
freaking crazy nonetheless
i know a little bit about free driving
and but and scuba diving has always been
like kind of like oh man that'd be a
cool and death you can just stay down
and breathe
the
kind of
dive rig that you eventually end up
using in the sale teams which is called
a rebreather a rebreather sure and it
has no bubbles yeah
and when you're down there just like
quiets like
yeah it's not like a normal
a normal when you're scuba diving with a
normal what's called an open circuit rig
he's like
it's so noisy there's bubbles everywhere
and i don't like it at all and i've
spent way more
i probably spent a hundred times more in
my life on draeger
what's true drager's the rebreather
then open circuit open circuit you
basically do it in buds you get
qualified
and then as soon as you're done with
that you go on closed circuit and that's
where you die for the rest of your
career
maybe every once in a blue moon you dive
open circuit i can't i think i do open
circle on a
ship one time to like clear some
some seaweed out of something or
something like this but but
have you ever gone scuba diving in any
capacity after you retired from the navy
would you like is that your jail like if
i create a rebreather yeah yes like just
to go or what or if if i was like let's
say we were went back to hawaii and we
were just going to go diving
and i could use a rebreather i'd
probably look into it maybe do it are
rebreathers like available or they are
but i don't know what the rules are you
know they're not available they're like
bluetooth no no you they are available
i've looked like you can buy one six
five or six thousand dollars you know
how much is a regular scuba rig like a
middle of the road i would guess 1500
bucks for the whole thing if you went
over to the dive shop and hooked it up
but that seems like to me anyway that
seems like a cool little just
certification you can just decide to go
you know just like even like the guns
thing like you know how to you know
those kind of certifications just have
more capability overall you just choose
plenty yeah and there's people that
chase those little qualifications right
yeah and i dig it yeah yeah but i mean
of course just like anything else just
like you know if you don't want to do it
for nothing they got to be applicable i
would think anyway yeah but it's better
to have the capability and certification
then let's build capability is what is
what we're saying you know which one i
randomly got um it's not randomized for
a reason but it seems but it seems like
you would never just think to go get it
but once you kind of think about it for
a second it's like super duper useful is
cpr
yeah i'm cpr certified
do you put that on your resume for this
job
i'm just saying if you see if you black
out or something like this i got you
brother
dude i didn't know i'm dealing with a
highly qualified
highly qualified individual i told you i
told you it's small but it's one of
those things you can just get and it's
better to have
better than that than ever
bro i'm just saying what did you like
apply to college go get that degree in
cpr
jack
all right so uh there you go
you're down if you go down remember text
echo charles he'll come and give you cpr
he's qualified
it's like a 15-minute class
bro i don't even know why i tell you
these
things i tell you anything i don't know
why you do you that's ridiculous
either way yeah if you want to represent
while you're on the path cpr certified
or not
[Laughter]
go to jackalstore.com
you can get your discipline equals
freedom
shirts and hats and there's a lot of
good stuff on there check it out
if you want something get something to
represent don't forget we got some other
podcasts too we got the jocko unraveling
with daryl cooper
we've got the grounded podcast warrior
kid podcast we got jocko underground
that's a huge way to support there's
people getting banned you got what just
happened
neil young told spotify get rogan off oh
yeah get him off straight up ultimately
and guess what happened what did you see
the outcome
neil young's off spotify
we should do we should say we we want
joe rogan off spotify yeah yeah or where
you're going to have to get this off to
be who are you
but listen that's a scenario that
happened yeah
luckily spotify
made the call to keep joe rogan because
neil young cool
i don't know if that happened to crosby
stills nash and young as well i don't
know if he screwed over all of his old
band mates too you know who knows what
happened there good old neil young but
you jacked it up son so we don't know
what's gonna happen we don't know if
somebody's gonna come on uh on the apple
and and we don't know if some big band
if neil young's gonna go on apple and
say hey take down jockle podcast
because i don't like what they're saying
about cpr calls
so we don't know if that's gonna happen
so that's why we have jackal underground
so if you wanna if you wanna get on
board there you wanna help us out cost
eight dollars and eighteen cents a month
to come and we the half full podcast
that we do there a little
a little bit of a little bit of a
project to pass more information if you
can't afford it it's okay email
assistant jockle underground.com so you
can be in the game check out our youtube
channel check out flipsidecanvas.com
with dakota meyer check it out i wrote a
bunch of books
[Music]
check them out i would say especially
check out the kids books most people
know i've written some books but some
people don't know i wrote kids books
kids books keep them kids on the path
and also we have echelon front which is
our leadership consultancy if you want
to have us help you with your leadership
go to extremeownership.com
and a
online training platform so look a few
years ago
if someone said hey you know i really
want to learn about leadership
uh do you can you help me
i'd say yeah i just listen to my podcast
man and they'd be like oh okay cool
thanks and they'd listen there's good
information
but now there's
300 plus podcasts and they're about war
and they're about
atrocities and so the leadership lessons
are strewn
throughout
[Music]
so we this is one thing that we've done
to sort of hey let's get these things
into a consolidated curriculum where you
can literally learn from step a through
step z there you go go to extreme
ownership.com little story about the
word strewn
so i got two i got three daughters the
two older ones they're very
they're very you know articulate well
they also get hostile
you know
that too okay and they shared room for a
long time
and they still share a room when they're
home
but
one of them
wrote the older one wrote a message to
the younger one that said you know
something along the lines of
listen
i just got home uh i've been out all day
working and i just got home and as soon
as i walked into a room i could barely
get in there because you had your
clothes and your stuff strewn about the
floor and i would really appreciate if
you come home and clean this up
and my middle daughter replied
strewn
that's all she wrote back
so i thought that was pretty funny
strewn so now it's a joke and inside of
our family if there's something been
left out then it's been there's then
it's strewned about and then the
response is just straight up strewn
about and if you want to help service
members active and retire go check out
mark lee's mom mama lee she's got an
awesome
charity organization if you want to
donate or get involved
go to america's mighty
mightywarriors.org
and if you need more of us for whatever
reason we're on social watch out for the
algorithm
i'm not trying to draw you into the
algorithm where that thing grabs a hold
of your soul and drags you down reading
into comments and feeling bad about
yourself
and
scanning to another screen and another
one i don't want you to do that
i don't want you to do that i'd rather
you not do that
but if you feel like oh i got a question
i want to
see what's happening cool
we're on the we're on the gram we're on
facebook we're on twitter echo's
adequate charles i am at jocko willing
and once again if you want to hang out
with chris gifford and his wife julie
go to instagram taking leave
underscore rv there you go that's julie
and chris who knows what they got going
on out there in the world in an
airstream what they say 30-foot
airstream yeah that's a nice ride right
there yeah nice ride
and speaking of chris gifford just want
to say thanks once again to chris on his
travels he was nice enough to stop by
he was a
silent professional in the teams
and a pro
and i appreciate it appreciate your
service and thanks for coming by and to
all the other vets out there
both
the vets
and also the folks that are still active
duty manning the watch worldwide thank
you for your continued service and to
our police and law enforcement of
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service all first
responders thanks for manning the watch
here at home and to everyone else
everyone else remember what chris did
with his life
he set a goal
and then he went out and he achieved it
and then he did that again and again and
again and that is a good plan
so go out there
come up with a goal
and execute
by getting after it and until next time
this is echo and jocko